the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
[Music]
club
hello everyone welcome back to San Louis
we're going to have another amazing
event here chess 9lx where the one and
only Gary Kasparov will be joining the
field together with a lot of strong
American chess players I cannot wait for
this event to start let's go to the
studio and get this tournament
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club presents chess 9 Alx some of the
best players in the world take on the
toughest format in
[Music]
chess hello and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master nazzi pay and I'm here with
Grandmaster Yas San Nasi so wonderful to
have you back at Studio here welcome
back to St Louis we missed you thank you
so much I'm so happy to be back me too
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
chess
9lx what on Earth is it I know it's
going to be very exciting but let's get
an Insight nassie what is chess
9lx right it was invented by Bobby
Fisher in
1966 right originally named Fisher
random also known as chess 960 named for
the 960 possible starting positions
except there are restrictions from those
possible position think about it you
don't want Bishops on the same color so
you got to put the Bishops on opposite
color in order to Castle the King has to
be between both Rooks and for this
tournament the players are only going to
receive the starting position 15 minutes
before the start of the play but the
players what a roster of players it is
uh do the honor please indeed we have an
incredibly strong lineup one and only
legendary Gary Kasparov it's Gary
Kasparov versus America look at that
look at who he's up against right we
have the top players in the United
States Fabiano Carana hiar Nakamura
leavon Ronan Wesley so murderer row on
the left side of the screen and we have
lenir Dominguez Sam Shanklin Ray Robson
and two youngsters Jeffrey Jong and Sam
seavan what challenges there are there
and tell us about the format for this
event it's going to be a 10 player rapid
round robin time control is 20 minutes
with 5sec increment and because it's 10
player rapid round Al that means there's
nine rounds of play it's going to be a
three-day event so three rounds each day
for the next three days please continue
in chest 9660 the back rank pces are
randomized and the new starting position
is drawn before each round but all
players will have the same starting
position exactly and there'll be a
playoff if there's a tie for first place
excitement excitement excitement and
we're very fortunate to have in studio
our dear friend Christian Christian
welcome back I know you've had a very
big uh day in the meanwhile
congratulations on your marriage thank
you very much yes sir good to see you
guys welcome chess fans to day one of
Chess 9lx here in St Louis this is going
to be just an amazing explosive event I
want to say and you guys showed us who
the players are but I want to highlight
three of them in particular and we're
going to start with the king of
streaming and of course that is
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura he's 35
years of age five-time US champion just
an impressive resume reigning world
Fisher random champion and the 2023
Norway chess winner and what a
tournament that was in the last round he
was trailing behind two points behind
Fabiano Carana with a victory because
for a victory you were getting three
points he would have won that event and
he did it he won that event in the last
round and speaking of Fabiano Carana he
will be facing him here because he is
back in St Louis after a long stint in
Europe and what a successful trip that
was 35 years of age two-time US champion
2022 9 champion and the 2022 American
Cup winner he's been very successful
here in St Lewis he also just last month
qualified for the 2024 candidates
tournament that is a marquee event and
he's very happy that he punched his
ticket to Toronto and of course the
legendary Gary casprov is back in St
Louis as well 60 years of age the former
world champion 15 years of dominance in
chess 19 chess Olympian medals and he's
also the founder of the grand chest to
just an amazing pack of players and as
you can see with his longtime supporter
Michael
kovski right now discussing potential
strategies for the event he had a rough
time last year but we're expecting him
to do quite well in this one we're going
to have a lot of explosive chess guys
thank you chess 9lx sorry not chess
chess 9lx thank you Christian indeed and
tell us Nasi I do the honors and uh
pairings for this first round we have
exciting paring ings we have Sam savan
playing against Leon aronian nice s
shank Clan playing Fabiano
Carana Olympic teammates for sure but
we're going to be saying that a lot so
we might might as well get it in right
now lir Dominguez playing Jeffrey Jean
our probably key match up Wesley saw
against Gary Kasparov you got me with
that one that looks like a marquee
matchup to be sure and a backup can be
Hikaru Nakamura against Ray Robson
absolutely outstanding pairings to get
underway and tell us what they're
fighting for these 10 players they're
fighting for a handsome prize fund there
is total of
$150,000 in prizes first place winner is
going to win $37,500 second place 25,000
third 20,000 very very nice and
everybody walks away with at least
7, understand why you wanted to get
back cuz we were discussing and we were
like yeah I we play
some get me in coach now and understand
why you
know now everybody's waiting for the big
reveal uh as the players uh getting uh
started and there's uh I bet you dollars
to Donuts that Gary's talking about the
ultimate moves games yesterday and what
could have been and what should have
been played and why it wasn't a good
decision car is just like okay you got
you're right yeah
yeah
car is the streamer in the group there
but take a look at what Gary is wearing
yesterday he was wearing a nice uh suit
right now he's L more comfortable
because he knows these games are going
to go down the wire and he's going to
have to be fast with his mechanics yeah
but what's up with the vest I'm very
curious about the vest excuse me with
the interest in fashion Choice yeah well
I'm you know hidden pockets for you know
uh certain chest positions that uh might
might pop up now I'm I'm curious what
position they're analyzing since they
don't know yet what position they're
going to
get and what you see there on that
monitor uh right beside Eric and uh
Sabina that monitor will have the reveal
so the idea is there's 960 positions and
I'm not sure if it's that's one but they
go through some
software and somebody's going to hit a
button and then the position's going to
pop up now basically what the players do
is they find somebody they're compatible
with and then they go and they just kind
of quickly talk about not their opponent
not their opponent but some kind of
strategy Fabiano and lenier kind of
teaming up potentially together exactly
now in the past Peter fidler and Gary
Kasparov famously teamed up and Peter
fidler came back with the wrong
position so was that on purpose
that was in complete accident so Gary
and Peter analyze the wrong position for
15 minutes before somebody pointed it
out to them let's say
Peter I bet pet was in Gary's dog house
for when Gary sat down at the board and
so it completed exactly it was not well
received it was bad news now Christian
have you ever uh thrown your hat in the
ring with the 960s only as a coach I was
uh in uh at the same tournament actually
that you were doing commentary for that
was the 2019 World Fisher random
Championship I think in h Norway in Oslo
that's we've had a lot of fun and that
was my first and to be honest only
experience as a coach or as a player in
chess 9 of course I've been playing uh
online some n and Le occasionally but
not so much as a coach though I have to
say I had a lot of fun we were allowed
to use the engines we were allowed to
use the computers we had maybe about 10
to 15 minutes in between the reveal and
the actual start of the game just like
they have in this one but we also had
access to the engine so we were trying
to use it to the best of our abilities
but I have to say it's very strange to
use the engine on CH 9x because some
position are saying that white is
completely winning out of the opening
out of the first few moves um and some
of them are completely equal it's quite
interesting and I do believe we have a
reveal and we'll be waiting ourselves
and N See jump right in how about
yourself have you played in a a Fisher
9lx uh not yet but I'm very motivated to
play yes well I'm sure at the end of
three days you'll be chomping at the bit
let me in okay I waiting for a r because
since uh there's no opening theories
developed yet I might actually have a
shot at right well for me that's the
beauty and here it comes this is the
reveal for starting position for round
walk
one Shuffle those back pieces Rook King
Bishop Knight so the way we break it
down when we see this position we we
look at the awkward pieces act in this
exact position all the pieces are fine
we're going to play G3 or G4 to release
the bishop the knights are fines the
bishop is fine there's a weakness
there's one Pond weakness and the pond
weakness is H2 and H7 but it's yeah it's
not so easy to Target those uh
weaknesses and as you predicted lanir
and uh Fabby I think that's leavon and
Fabiana is that leavon yes oh excuse me
recogniz his
glasses and I think it's more than just
the two of them I I think we see another
figure right there and perhaps that's
lineer the one on the right so in this
starting position you would be thinking
to Castle alongside more since King's
already on B1 well let me see if I can
just uh refresh my board to figure it
out myself Sam Shanklin and R Ray Robson
analyzing no I don't have uh I don't
have my reshuffle uh do you have a
reshuffle by chance not yet it hasn't
happened I will let you know but we can
kind of see it on the screen and kind of
try to understand what they're doing
what I'm spotting is that on the queen
side things are going to develop quite
normally I'm going to go Knight C3 get
the bishop out either on the wrong
diagonal or on E3 or F or somewhere
around there and then I'm just going to
Castle La well I can imagine that
D4 Bishop F4 the London system if you
will as a way of Defending H2 now now
the players are looking at F4 and F5 G4
that's okay that's leevon the grub
that's leevon right opening up the
bishop does make sense right that for
for sure uh but
G4 not a big fan of it could be an
option also for white to start with B3
Fano the bishop yep play Knight C3 and
Castle along yes that way the the queen
need move in order to get out of the way
and there we see G G4 D G6 D5 stops
black knight from going to C6 and Knight
on d8 is very uncomfortable well but boy
when you you know Grandmasters we're
we're always making those comparisons
right this looks like a very good
Leningrad Dutch in the sense that oh now
you can't Castle on that side you can
Castle long which is actually very short
I don't think very sure I don't think
I've ever seen Leningrad Dutch with
longside castles no no that's not a
frequent and it looks like uh Sam
Shanklin and Ray Robson uh kind of
teaming up by the way that's I mean Ray
and Sam are both on the bubble of making
the Olympic team we have these
extraordinarily top four players and
then uh the fight for the fifth place
it's just it's intense Sam doesn't seem
to be very happy with the bishop on H1
after this move yeah once you start with
E4 Bishop on H1 is going to be unhappy
true true uh so I think first moves B3
or D4 look the best to me for for for me
D4 yeah I really do like I think there's
a problem with B black Coast
G6
[Laughter]
with now uh just to remind everybody uh
the players are looking at the starting
position for the first time uh right now
and they get 15 minutes and only 15
minutes then the clock is going to begin
and they've got to come up
with well I think the the goal is uh the
the scheme of development you know where
are the pieces is going to go I like
what you were just saying about B3 G6 by
the way but then if you continue the
thought Bishop B2 Bishop takes B2 Knight
takes B2 you've helped
develop Whit's pieza so but Knight on B2
is not the best place pie no no I'm not
I'm not a big fan either as we see our
legendary Gary kaspar let's talk about
Gary for a moment because Gary of course
loves chess but there's no way with his
busy schedule that he can keep up with
the players and the uh Theory so but
when he thinks about the Fisher random
and there's no chess Theory then he
wants to get in but the problem is and
Christian you can speak to this more
directly he's not used to be under Fire
it's one thing to do training it's
another thing to play tournament chess
no absolutely and it's all about that
that time expenditure you just don't
feel the position you're not confident
in your moves when you have a haven't
played in so many well years to be
honest right now because he's playing
sure maybe one tournament every now and
then every couple of years we've seen
him here at the St Louis chess club
often but only momentarily and only
generally in chess 9 LX so he's not very
well versed with his opening Theory
which doesn't matter in this one but he
also doesn't feel the pieces as much
right when you're not playing chess all
the time you're going to spend a lot of
time in the first few moves trying to
figure things out and then there's going
to be as you mentioned a lot of pressure
in those last uh critical moments of the
game exactly as we've got just a little
bit of time we're going to put our panel
on the spot we're going to ladies first
your choice who's going to win the
tournament N I thought about that
already and my pick is Wesley s wow uh
we've got one Christian who's going to
win the tournament I got to go with the
defending Champion Fabiano caran
hey where everybody's happy I'm going to
go with the
reigning Fisher random world champion
and that would be Hikaru Nakamura good
pick and darou everybody's got a
favorite Dar is going with lenir
Dominguez I like that wow and Sabina
made her Pig and it's Leon ran wow no
duplications in any of that top five use
[Laughter]
sounds like it to me my goodness no
nobody pick Gary I mean guys nobody come
on Gary Gary's Rusty we just talked
about that Gary is your guy though it's
true I that is true by the way again and
I just want to boldly uh
reinforce what you said Fabiano caruana
last month qualified for I believe the
fifth to the candidates world
championship tournament and our sincere
congratulations to him I think a lot of
players uh judge their careers by
whether they played for the world
championship or how many how often they
qualified for the candidates I only
qualified twice myself but uh that is an
extraordinary achievement to qualify
once a candidate always a candidate
there you go whenever you analyze a
player and you analyze his or her
careers yes you always look at these big
moments this Pinacle of uh chess uh
candidates world championship match
these are the two big big ones and
Fabiano qualifying five times just
simply impressive exactly throw in some
national championship titles and maybe a
couple Olympic appearances and that's
what it's all about and of course the
most important thing in all of that
according to Bent Larson winning yes
winning great that's why qualifying the
candidates you're one step away but it's
just not yet enough that looks like the
table right there I mean there you're
seeing five of the 10
participants uh looking over one another
shoulder Jeffrey jeang standing up
facing us Sam Sean with his back to us
Wesley so uh uh in their uh discussing
been a good one yeah no and I do think
that that's very important that uh in
this tournament in particular the
players are feeling so very comfortable
because they're not under the pressure
of the ELO there is a tyranny in the
world of chess the Tyranny is you need
that top rating to get to the Grand
chess tour to get to those big uh in
invitations so often times the players
play a kind of a risk averse chess
here they swing for the fences Christian
you said
excitement yeah we're going to have the
most exciting games when they're not
worried about their yo exactly do you
feel it's always about Prestige of
course for these top players and
bragging rights to be honest because if
you win any Tournament being chess 960
rapid Blitz you name it as long as you
touch the chess pieces and you win a
tournament you're going to have braging
RS for
exactly do you feel that in your uh
practice uh Nasi that uh you you have an
awareness of your rating and you
jockeying I don't know for Olympic spots
or Ken cup or something like that is
that go through your mind I've stopped
playing a lot of open tournaments to
make sure I always qualify for the US
championship and American Cup and the
Olympia right because those are the te
those are the uh appearances that you
really want to show up for yeah
yeah and a unique aspect of this event
is that players can actually talk to
each other I know I mean there's a
restriction you don't don't speak in the
playing Hall and here you see not only
the players talking they're
collaborating And discussing uh actual
chess moves but they're only this
friendly 10 minutes before the round
exactly once the round begins they the
knives are drawn and suddenly they're
fierce
gladiators but isn't that too many chefs
in the kitchen this is my question for
you guys because I see I'm seeing a very
very quiet Jeffrey Jean Jeffrey just is
absorbing it all and there's also Sam
Sean so you see Jeffrey maybe go with
Sam Sean go pair up with Sam Sean well
he's not spoiling the broth right right
we remember last year Ali Resa was
throughout the event by himself yes and
he made a very Salient point he said
that we've been analyzing chess for
thousands of years and right now you're
going to solve this position in 5
minutes or like 15 minutes or whatever
it doesn't matter that's I'm going to
chill I'm going to chill instead I'm
going to look at the position on my
diagram I'm going to try to make my own
predictions of where the pieces should
go and then just go play a game of 911
sorry to interrupt you there but if I
have to see a focus B Jeffrey was like
in some other Zone he was really
absorbing everything uh that was being
said and played that that is
concentration squared I mean nothing but
the chest position is going through in
this position that got picked position
267 white has any advantage in the
beginning this looks you know it's funny
because the stockfish chess engines have
calcul ated and ranked each and every
one of the 960 positions and there are a
number of positions that are
extraordinarily balanced very even at
the start and there's a number of
positions that are actually a very
serious qualified Advantage for
white this strikes me as one of the more
balanced ones how about you uh I I think
the same way yes um because the weakness
is on H2 and H7 and it's not you know if
you play a move like like for example C2
C4 and the Queen on B1 can't capture H7
there's no threat to those pawns then
there's no real weakness at the very
start of the position well it seems like
the players are about yeah in their
seats I I think they've got the
two-minute warning as you might say
football so they're going to their
finding their boards by the way I just
have to say once again a big shout out
to the house of ston these incredibly
beautiful chess sets I mean every time I
see these beautifully carved triple
weighted sets you know on these gorgeous
boards it's like I want to play I mean I
want to play look at that look at to
play in October I
know you know I I used to get these
simultaneous around the United States
and it was impossible for me to carry 40
chess boards and and sets with me so I
invited people to bring their own boards
and sets and boy I got to tell you I
played with red
pieces white pieces chess boards that
looked like they hadn't been washed in
like 20
years and off comes the coat and this is
the 9lx uh swag that the players have
been giving the shirt and they're
looking great by the way that gold
however you want to call that's very
very nice color exactly it's a Champions
color
right and start with the Wesley and G's
game let me I must say once again I do
not have the chess board
up but uh nassie your choice where would
you like us to begin would you like us
to start with the Sam Shanklin Fabby
game or way I'm I'm for kasparov's game
Kasparov Wesley so we're going to bring
up they this is the
authentication of I do believe the chess
sets as pieces of History are put put up
for auction really and so they need an
authentication by the players that they
played with this set on this date and I
think that's what that is but I could be
wrong my guess is that they're signing
that they're playing the right position
and they've been given in the right
position ah the ARs are looking for a
they're looking for a release D official
checklist what is that because you see
there's round one round two the look the
Arbiters are looking for
indemnification you can't sue
us well especially after the vler
casparo we gave you the proper position
it is your
responsibility I'm sorry it cost you
first
place and we're underway we're off that
was an awkward handshake I must say I
didn't uh come off look like it was
going to be a fist Bop yeah it was some
kind of a combination there as E2 E4
we're we're underway and again I'm sorry
to say yes no I do have four but we have
a standard chest position we have a
standard chest position the pieces
haven't been sh E4
B3 well after Gary played E5 now Bishop
on h8 is closed on that diagonal so B3
makes a lot of sense okay but
uh do you think black should also play
B6 right it's kind of a copy the when I
see the move E4 B3 I'm usually seeing it
in combination with D2 D4 right or F2 F4
now because there is this Rook on F1 I
do believe that uh Bishop B2 and F4
might be on the agenda of uh Wesley D2
pardon me D7 D6 opening of the bishop I
think this is like the the most awkward
moments in fiser random in the first
five 10 moves and just figuring out what
the proper scheme of development is now
Gary his whole life has been a natural
born King's Indian defense point right
so he's going to love the fact that his
Bishop is already sitting on h8 and he's
going to be looking to play F5 himself
Knight to
F6 and now what he could try to do he
could Castle short on yes he could
develop his Bishop Knight and the queen
and the Knight on G8 and then just swoop
the king all the way to G8 exactly and I
the king's Indian you know again and I'm
thinking that would be uh the case and
again I'm sorry I've got the same
positions of my my pieces on the first
rank apologies but uh imagining that I
have uh the position I do I do think
that the move F7 F5
without the move G6 like you can just
play F5 Knight F6 and prepare short
castling um so my question for you
please Christian are we sure we're
calling in ch Le short Castle short
castle and long Castle long Castle is
that debated enough or no I think uh I
think that looks like a long Castle to
me yeah yeah yeah that's going to King
going from B8 to G8 that might qualify
as a long Castle but we're going to keep
our uh to not confuse ourselves exactly
exactly we're going to keep it since the
good plan good plan the thing is since
the position at the beginning is
flexible maybe we should keep our
lexicon flexible as well exactly by the
way Knight E7 I didn't expect that again
to my way of thinking that's prepping
F5 but the Knight is not going to be you
think want to retake with the Knight on
F5 yes that's what exactly what is what
I'm thinking his plan his plan is is to
recapture with a knight but for me when
you play F5 you really I like the Knight
on F6 how do you think Wesley should uh
prepare for F5 should he prepare F4 or
just D3 F3 options I think F4 I mean uh
be aggressive if I if white started
right now with the move F4 again
thinking about the tension of the
Bishops I agree you could take on F4
Rook takes F4 that ruins my right to
Castle on the king
side Knight E3 he wants to Castle first
but I was going to say F4 ef4 Rook F4
the bishop on B2 these a the bishop on
ah h8
uh is Meaningful 93 we we do we got the
chest positions okay better late than
never as we say and uh let me just bring
uh we have F5 on the board Gary playing
his aggressive style typical uh here's
what I was thinking a moment ago about
the move F2 F4 oh I'll wait for my
analysis board to just there what I was
suggesting a moment ago is I do if in
such a position give up the right to
Castle I move my Rook but I was just
thinking that because this bishop on B2
looks at the bishop on h8 it's not going
to be easy for black to they could try
to trade it with G6 yes exactly and then
you then you too lose the right to
Castle instead we did see the move
Knight E3 F5 e takes F5 Knight takes F5
and I love this move uh that's thinking
outside of the box right you Castle
right there uh without having to move
the you Castle queenside I mean to say
without having to move the queen I like
it knight uh Castle Gary deay Castle in
might be an issue for him because now
white can play G3 or even G4 with the
tempo and that Bishop on H1 can be quite
dangerous true true no question about it
here again I I think and the best move
here is actually and you guys mentioned
the plan very nicely it's to open up the
Rook with F4 right open up the bishop on
B2 as well exactly and try to create
some tension in the center right the
best move in the position for black
right now is not to go Knight C6 exactly
as G5 to stop the move F4 open up the
bishop and get more space on the king
side I like the move G5 to stop F4 I
think Wesley might have missed that and
and in Fisher random chess you don't
always get a lot of opportunities to do
whatever it is you want to do sometimes
a move like D5 just will shut you down
from playing moves like F4 so I think
Wesley's kn3 was a little L of days ago
Christian and again this is what the
problem has been with Kasparov last year
as well he's spending so much time
opening phase and right now he's down to
his last 16 minutes four minutes that's
a lot of minutes out of 20 for the first
six moves not good enough you're going
to have huge problems later on in the
later stages of the game well I I hear
you loud and clear I
won't let's go right let's go say move
faster stronger right yes but in this
particular case and this is a practical
decision as you see Wesley much more
practical with his clock um the point is
uh what I wanted to say is you're right
Gary has used four minutes and for seven
moves probably bad time management but
that's not as egregious as using 10
minutes for one move which is something
we saw last year did that yeah as some
really really bad time management G7 G5
very quickly Wesley said I hear you I
hear you uh you've opened up your Bishop
I'll do likewise move G3 by the way does
support for let's just take a look
around the horn as we're going to go to
uh my pick hikaro Nakamura versus uh Ray
Robson uh something very symmetrical
about this position
uh okay we'll leave the Symmetry alone
we'll go to Sam Shanklin and aabi okay
now this is very very distant for a
second I thought there was a Checkmate
threat already but forgot that Knight's
on D1 okay that was my opening move uh
chosen by Sam and then we did see this
kind of a
Leningrad uh Dutch uh being uh
considered analyzed Knight D5 okay so
winning a Tempo but The Bishop's popped
out okay Knight E3 suggesting that the
tempo is going to be one
back Bishop D2 and there is a
checkmating threat all right Knight's
not on D1 anymore exactly there is the
the the something I I have this theory
in regular chess I don't know if it's
applicable to uh uh Fisher random the
theory goes like this if one might ever
allows a check Maiden one threat in the
opening he's done something
wrong you normally you don't get the
Checkmate in one threat Knight went back
to
D1 oh so you were right it wasn't a
Checkmate threat I was expecting Bishop
C3 wow what a strange Retreat be good to
go back to1 right of course not I well I
think Sam couldn't see the the
compensation after Bishop C3 Queen C3
Queen takes E2 he said I'm losing PA was
hanging yeah I'm losing a pawn and I
don't see why I should do that but the
move Knight D1 is a kind of well I I did
something wrong sorry F5 F4 and we're up
to date and with the game and uh
probably black is uh for Choice let's
just it's actually white for
Choice very much so especially after the
last couple of moves and we see see Sam
already pouncing on the opportunity to
create some problems for that Queen on
B5 A4 follow it up even with B3 you can
even play the move B3 in this position
B3 that it's a very weird way of playing
but maybe that Knight belongs to B2 and
then after King A2 and Rook to D1 maybe
Knight to C4 hitting up the bishop on E5
it's not that easy for black to finish
his development on the queen side and
the King side as well it it's funny
because it it it felt like an egregious
waste of Tempe Knight D1 to E3 back to
D1 but if white gets away with this and
ends up with an edge he wins a lot of
Tempe back by attacking the queen A4 B3
and I think we noticed this last year as
well space Advantage is so important if
I remember
correctly by the end of the tournament
we kind of started understanding
standing by space Advantage is an
important one that's exactly right uh
really symmetrical position let's look
at Dominguez Jeff game uh where are you
board three lanir is White against
Jeffrey Jun you're right this is the
Fisher random equivalent of a Queen's
Gambit accepted kind of ending and equal
extremely equal balanced nice uh just
checking in on iaru and uh Ray once
again I because I saw this kind of
crafty move and I must say I liked it
very much move Bishop
A6 uh kind of tit fortat Bishop A3
trying to say to White well if you
you're not going to Castle kingside you
know I'm going to cover the F1 don't
want to play Rook
G1 so I think white might have to play
C4 but that's one of the moves that you
kind of resist right you play a move
like C4 you know you're giving up the
Outpost D4 so something like uh C4
Knight
E6 nothing terrible of course but the
Knight might land on D4 okay your knight
might land on D5 as well Queen side
might be a little weak since we are
keeping the King on the queen side well
let's okay he did play Rook G1 he did
play yeah there was some reason to
resist C4 Knight C6 on the board and I
think Ray's doing just fine here a game
we haven't seen yet let's just jump to
it Sam seon versus leavon aronian
whenever I look at levon's games I
always have the feeling that I'm living
in a parallel universe and leavon is you
know the master of his Universe please
similar situation as in Fab's game where
father's Queen was on B5 here Sam's
Queen's on B4 and went to C5 and looks
like White's Queen's going to be
attacked a couple times like bumped
around if you will and I'm not loving
White's position no I can't say that I
am either uh now having said that just
give me a move for a moment just uh uh
oh yep there is Bishop F5 ideas right
you can tickle my C2 Pawn that might
well I suppose Sam at least in his mind
is threatening to capture twice like if
I if black were to throw out Bishop F5
again uh aiming and you were to
capture after for example a move like
G6 uh even
nice you won't be able to play Bishop B3
because guess what he got an A5 a fun
stuff Christian what what's crazy here
is that white king can disappear from
this side right and quickly Castle short
and Black's conversation will be gone
like like yeah just I I do appreciate
that I'm blundering my E2 pawn and in
this this case blundering my B2 Pawn but
I did how about your queen yes sir oh
sorry uh yeah blundering both uh this is
what I really wanted to do display now
let me try to Castle I think you're
supposed to put it on top of the rug yes
there yeah there you go uh that is the
king going from B1 to G1 folks that's
pretty fun nice uh Christian what has
caught your eye well Fab's in trouble my
pick on unfortunately in this one is in
big big trouble and take a look at what
happened the queen landed on A6 after
this A4 Queen C4 B3 Queen A6 I have to
say Sam has been playing the best moves
in the position and they're not very
intuitive because you are opening up
your king quite a lot uh on the queen
side so this is quite an interesting and
intriguing approach from white but it
definitely delivers the results because
right now how are you going to develop
and deal with the passive Knight on G8
if you go Knight F6 obviously you're
losing the pawn on F4 if you go Knight
H6 is just simply not the right uh
Avenue for the Knight you can take take
Knight to D3 everything is coming with
tempo for white and you still hav't
Castle on the queen side Bishop takes G
uh D2 Queen takes D2 now you have to
worry about the Knight on H6 I have
Knight to F4 coming this E6 square is
going to be a nice landing spot for that
Knight this is pretty much all she wrote
for uh black this is not looking good so
what do you do how do you develop your
pieces maybe you want to Castle right
and how do we do the castle we move the
king over uh The Rook castle like this
but unfortunately after take take once
again it's all about the tempies you
take Knight to D3 everything with the
tempo you still have problems on the
dark squares where is this queen on A6
going so far away from uh the play in
the position Queen to D2 maybe Queen to
G5 and start attacking and posing some
problems for the bishop Pawn A3 uh H3
also I can just simply start pushing my
Pawns in the center E4 E5 open up the
center and just take advantage of the
fact that my piec have a job have
something to do your pieces
don't that's kind of remarkable because
I had to I have to admit that I would
easily be seduced by the move Bishop H3
thinking I'm I'm winning a Tempo I'm
forcing The Rook to a
square and you can't Castle but on the
other hand this bishop on
H3 could be you know potentially trapped
the G3 G4 and like you were saying it
doesn't have a good Retreat sores the
desirable Bishop F5 would just run into
G3 takes F4 and you're right Fabby is
surprisingly facing some real questions
he's much worse right now I think the
biggest problem is the queen on A6 how
do we get that Queen back into the game
well yeah it's if I try to go uh Visa B6
Knight C4 is a nasty Fork uh we'll keep
an eye on this one as that would be in
our estimation quite an upset uh to
start our tournament just jumping back
to the game of uh Gary and Wesley for a
moment when we have le left it we were
full of admiration for the move G5 and
also for the Practical uh response G3
Knight to D4 okay I'm gonna point out
that actually Wesley already has a huge
time Advantage 16 minutes against nine
minutes um and we're only on move 10 by
the way uh Gary moved his Knight moved
his Knight again so that's two temp C3
for the yeah but is that a good judgment
like to Tempe and Wesley said well I'm
going to be developing my pieces while
you're jumping to and fro and I don't
see C2 C3 as being
injurious uh to White whereas I do do
think that you know these Tempe
could you know be good for for for for
white like okay first of all he is
threatening to win a pawn uh jumping on
this one too Christian this one I don't
know uh it seems like Gary is the thing
is the position remains extremely
balanced uh the one thing that is not
balanced is their time situation right
uh Wesley has more than
double his time so this is not looking
good for Gary for the simple fact that
he's spending too much time forget about
the time for a moment just tell me what
he should be doing in the position
because it's not like if you take you
can start exchanging so you let's say if
you take let's take on E3 okay uh just
to point out what I see is a as as a bad
line if you take on F4 I'll take on F5
you take on F5 now your queen needs uh
you must trade issues exactly that's
where the loss of development comes you
Castle here long it wouldn't be bad
right no castling while you're in Check
N uh so but you were about to suggest
taking on E3 Christian I recapture now I
take on F4 I recapture and you I take
back and I
recapture and also by the way I'm not
sure if I would take with the G Pawn but
okay let's say take take there's also an
in between move maybe bishop G4
developed with a Tempo so black I can do
that I can do that I can also just
exchange absolutely everything on F4 and
then try to go uh A5 open up the
position on that side yes okay that is a
surprise move for me so the idea is you
won't move your bishop and you won't
cast or Ry You'll Play A5 I'm starting
to play for initiative on the queen side
I'm giving you the H7 Pawn if you really
want it and then I'm I'm just saying
that what would two wonderful Pawn
grubbers do in this
situation without
thinking so take it take it you got us
you I'm kind of curious you had me at
hello all right let's continue Christian
has support of the engine ah but forget
about that we I mean don't trust those
chess engines they're not what they're
what they're cracked up to be A4 let's
do it okay um
it looks a bit scary right it does well
Scary For Whom like okay I'll go back I
just Bishop C2 I'll just pretend like
you're attacking me Gary's down to six
minutes that's the problem I'm telling
you that's just so that's you see the
that's where the lack of practice the
lack of awareness this uh you you you're
you're not under enough tension of the
tournament that the tournament tensions
do bring and he we anticipated this the
beginning he's going to definitely speed
up right as he plays more games but
Knight takes E3 as you predicted uh
Christian is on the board there are
still options this is one it's a very
imbalanced position this A5 sure with
the help of the engine it's easy to spot
and easy to understand that you have
enough compensation when you're facing
this over the board you start thinking
hey do I really want to give up that
pawn on H7 and allow white to get a
potential pass Pawn on the H file that's
probably not a good idea so I'm going
defend that maybe take a more passive
stance and that might be problematic
that's why he's spending so much time
it's not for nothing right if you guys
don't mind switching position let's look
at hikaru's game I really like raise
Knight on
D4 that is a gorgeous Outpost I for
folks who uh really do follow our
broadcast you will hear me say this on
multiple
occasions uh Knights have a very
intriguing property one of the
properties that Knights have is the more
often they're defended the more powerful
they are it's the strangest thing but
that Knight on D4 is really one of the
most best defended Knights I've seen in
a long long time defended four times but
it could easily be defended six times
Knight C6 Queen D7 you got it uh nice
but yeah I do like what Ry has done I'm
assuming he wants to recapture with the
pawn and
we could have a an intriguing position
like night takes and here I just want to
stop take with the eom you know but the
desire to keep the phones connected is
is to keep this uh but this allows
Knight
D5 and uh there's a potential exchange
sacrifice in the position I don't know
if this is what do look very strong they
do don't they I mean medicine to be with
the support of two Bishops as well
exactly right uh intriguing pH might be
in
trouble my pick what's going on wait a
minute my pick is doing great Wesley
Wesley Wesley okay it's not over yet on
it's still quite complicated Wesley
let's jump Hikaru versus and he did like
your Bishop G4 Tempo the move A5 and A4
leaving the bishop on C8 that's not
intuitively obvious I would have played
also like yourself Bishop
G4 um
wait a minute hold on that there might
be a trick there might be a problem
right I think with Bishop G4 Gary is
planning into Castle now not play A5
anymore yes exactly so I I suddenly uh I
I paused my I stopped myself because I
was thinking takes takes takes takes
uh-oh the move Bishop G4 was very clever
you forc The Rook onto a vulnerable
Square forgetting the fact that I'm
leaving my own Bishop hanging I thought
aren't I winning a p P yes I am but I'm
losing one as well okay so this is the
current position and Wesley is thinking
could Wesley sacrifice The Exchange do
we have something
aggressive since black is behind in
development little bit sure okay so
let's have a look he's looking at Bishop
takes
C6 Queen takes C6 Pawn takes
E5 uh so you don't have time to take the
Rook because I'll recapture this one no
but maybe I can actually take right how
what so take the Rook take the Rook no
no on F1 sorry yes Rook takes F1 Rook
takes F1 Bishop take oh I can't take H
and he did Rook D1 and very quickly
Castle L okay so I think I know what he
wanted not to take on F1 but to go Rook
to
E8 sorry what what what did he want so
if you take on C6 Queen C6 you take on
E5 yes now I can just simp go Rook E8
right Rook E8 and say to White okay uh
deal with this guy Knight yeah okay and
I'm taking the pawn back yeah uh none of
this happened because in fact what what
uh Wesley did play was rookie one and we
saw very quickly
Castles by uh
Gary uh by the way did you say Wesley
was doing well well the clock here on
the clock three times more think after
castles black let grab the pawn on H7
Gary's playing the best moves well I
mean grabbing the pawn on H7 does invite
Queen H5 um Gary's playing the best
moves no doubt about it the problem is
he's just taking too much time to play
them but he is in control of the
position if he doesn't fall the last
couple of minutes he's still in control
of the position right now not only that
maybe he has a slight advantage
okay let's so Wesley should keep the
position complicated not exchange a lot
of pieces so he can win on
time I was going to grab a pond uh check
out this for provocator uh take on C6
Queen takes C6 take on
E5 Bishop takes Bishop takes take on A7
A7 didn't see that look I'm a pond
Grover I
mean I'm always looking
case I'm a little bit unhappy because I
think the Bishops are tremendous
compensation sorry take on H2
unfortunately um but I can maybe start
with B6 maybe right and uh maybe
Christian might have missed in terms of
capturing on a h no no I did miss it I
said I cannot do it no no no that was a
trick that was a very dirty trick he was
he was slow on the update but once he
got it very dirty trick uh but B7 B6 I
know your foxy
Wes yeah um okay it's not really a pawn
I want to Grub as uh as uh Wesley but on
the other hand I feel uh this night on
G1 uh Christian guys this look this is a
great position and it's going to develop
nicely but there is a couple that are
exploding right now first of all Fabby
is pretty much completely lost and there
is a problem with the next couple of
games that I will show you is that right
now they look like chess games and
that's a problem right because whenever
everything is in completely different
ways chess 960 you don't really
understand what's happening in the
position maybe you can find some
resources but once the position starts
resembling chess games and you're also
lost you know that these Elite level
players are going to squeeze uh every
ounce of opportunity out of those
positions and this is exactly what Sam
Shanklin is doing right now great
position two Bishops that Knight on G4
not really doing much you have that nice
Center a lot of uh pawns and control in
the center and once that Bishop on H1
opens up E5 is going to come at some
point once that Bishop opens up it's
high time for you with black pieces
you're going to have huge huge problems
with the King it it's strange because
Fab's Queen ended up on a on a bad
Square on A6 and it's not really rescued
itself on the C6 in fact uh E4 E5 does
look very compelling as Sam is enjoying
this position uh what's your thoughts
speaking of when Christian said when the
position transposes to standard position
it's very visible who's better and if we
switch to Leon's game okay uh look at
that mon for white that's still on G1 I
think it can stay on G1 if black gets E4
in well then we'll be locked up and uh
nowhere to go uh yeah these double pawns
on you that's the thing about the Fisher
random positions of course at the start
of the game everything's randomized and
then both players are
seeking uh common sensibility if ground
that they're familiar with so the
positions do tend to standardize not if
you were to put the pawn on E2 on the F2
Square I would call it a balanced game
leaving it on E2 and E3 you've got to
like black but having said that black to
move I think Leon is going to play E4 E4
open up his bishop and kill the Knight
on G1 well the one thing I would say is
that uh this queen on
C4 does kind of do a lot of good things
uh I tend to look at these positions and
and I say what's my opponent's best
piece what's my my worst piece I might
be tempted to play the move Queen C6
myself another move that I'm also
tempted by is a move F5 just that if I
do play
E4 the night might land on the F4 square
and uh what are the clock times in this
one uh I think it's even six minutes for
both okay there you see two
well practiced tournament players
competitors yeah yeah with they're
active they play all the time equal time
on the clock they know they can't afford
to get two minutes behind and so on uh
Christian what's caught your eye well I
was looking at this one as well but take
a look at what's happening in Nakamura
versus Robson because that's a big one
as well and take a look at this last
move I was looking at the position and I
understand this beautiful Pawn on D4
gives black the advantage and Nakamura
understands that as well he knows that
that right now 6 minutes for Ray 8
minutes almost 9 minutes for Hikaru so
he needs to take the bull by the horns
open up the position complicate matters
and try to take advantage of Ray's time
situation and the uing time trouble and
that's exactly what he did he played the
move B4 it's weakening he knows it
believe me he knows it he plays B4 he
knows it's not the right way he knows
his King on B1 is going to be highly
exposed but he also understands that he
needs to create some counter chances and
right now things are getting explosive
in the position an interesting way for
black and the preferred way for Black by
the engine is either Queen to D7 or just
simply The Retreat Bishop to B7 I'm
wondering why not take well that's
pretty clear to see because right now my
Bishop gets active I'm going to maybe
open your king your own King as well
Black's king with a move C5 I have ideas
of Knight to B3 and it's very uh tricky
because in the future for example let's
say Rook to G8 I go Knight B3 I'm not
sure you can take on C4 that easily
because after Rook to C1 you have some
problems on the open C5 so it's a very
intriguing position we do have Queen D7
on the board that's a great move that's
a great move by Ray and let's try to
understand why not just simply take the
pawn right right take take I think Rook
E8 in fact Rook to E8 is the move yeah
that you get the Rook with Tempo away
from the bishop idea he he understood
there's something about Ray he always
gets down to his last few minutes and he
plays perfect chess when he has like one
minute on his clock it's very intriguing
he's been doing this his whole career
maybe that's something that kept him
back a little bit in his development but
he's extremely extremely good when the
clock is whing down I think that's one
of the most frustrating player opponents
you can play is you're playing against a
person who's perpetually in time trouble
and then when your opponent's in time
trouble they outplay you completely
authoritatively and you know you feel
like you never had a chance and it's so
frustrating sorry you were about to say
there few players like that gisho comes
to right totally yeah and they outplay
you I love the queen D7 move besides
rookie eight which is a brilliant move I
think there's some ideas for black to
play D3 and put the queen on D4 and just
go for the M oh yes oh yes if you could
get the that kind of battery that Bishop
on h8 lurking for my for for for for my
money that move Rook
E8 Knight E4 kind of a and like you were
saying with the D3 the other thing to
keep in mind and we're just going to go
back just a
moment if it was my turn I would as
black I Ray did play the move Queen D7
I'd love the move Queen A4 right I mean
you you're not going to play King B2 and
you know you're not going to retreat
your Bishop because I'm going to go
Queen takes B4 the problem with the
immediate Queen A4 or is that check it's
a little bit uh disruptive right so if
we play Queen
D7 and then we stutter step with Rook E8
then we get to play Queen A4 and it's
really good sorry from Hikaru he played
Queen F1 in anticipation of Rook to E8
now can we play Queen a no Queen D3
there still Queen G2
ideas possibly needs to be calculated
because there's Knight E4 well is it
made can I take the bishop
oh that's risky Queen A8 Jack well I I I
I'll walk through the go be desert for a
Pawn King D7 you can't imagine what I do
for a bishop but the problem
is yes please the problem is I I also
have just Perpetual if I want to I can
go Queen C6 Queen A8 and that's not
something that Ray wants to allow even
if he doesn't get checkmated right
there's still this Perpetual he doesn't
want that okay but take a look at this
right now if he spots it he's completely
winning with a move Knight to
E4 we have our first result Dominguez
and Jeffrey Drew their game that's the
CH 60 Berlin endgame the solid sorry he
has a win does Ray KN to E4 is dominant
in this position right now and the idea
is if you do take my Pawn if you go
Knight takes C4 F takes C4 and Bishop
takes C4 after D3 I have just too many
squares to create the battery G7 and D4
you don't have a way to stop it and once
I create that battery on the long
diagonal as we have seen with the
blacking with that Queen landing on G2
this is problems for the white king he
doesn't go for it understandably so
because it's not easy right well I mean
he when he played the move Queen D7 I I
really it's not like he had uh B oculars
on and but you know you're focused on
Knight E4 the funny part is playing
Knight E 4 right away with the Rook on
f8 also made a great deal of sense cuz
the Rook on f8 was actually pretty well
uh position there uh a golden
opportunity missed by Ray and uh Hikaru
said well my queen on E1 was terrible
and placing the queen on D3 is really
good it also stops Black's idea D3
precisely but how about Knight G4 G
Knight attacking F2 possibly H2 but I'm
not really
over there what you are looking for to
play Knight E5 and just kick your queen
out and then still play D3 uh no
seriously all very very sensible now I'm
not 100% sure how big a threat Knight F2
is because we we've been looking at
these Queen batteries like oh you're
going to take on H1 you're not going to
take on D1 I'm laughing at myself I was
going to take on C5 inviting you to take
my Rook forgetting that you could take
my bishop and I was going to go check
and I have at least picking up
everything on the quein side yeah
exactly uh but you
do uh have the possibility of capturing
I think night G4 white has to spend a
Tempo defending F2 well tell me why
again if I take Knight F2 Queen F3 let's
take on H1 I'll check you King C7 check
B6 is hanging yeah Bishop yeah this is
not good this is not what you wanted
when you went in for this but on the
other hand Knight F2 B Tak C5 I mean
it's sort of like these are the
positions where you know uh something uh
could go uh dreadfully wrong this is
where you need a time on the clock to
calculate but Ray only has one minute
one minute to four one minute against
almost five minutes yes wow and uh
Christian jump in on this move Knight G4
do you see this is uh something that Ray
should that's the best move in the
position but he's falling down to his
last one minute guys we have to pick a
game and stay with that one because
we're going down to the last couple of
minutes and Gary is down to his last
minute and 30 seconds Ray under one
minute which one will it be you guys
choose nass see I think we should uh
watch uh Hikaru and Ray's g game because
it's you made very sharp you made a very
executive and bold decision there as you
exu our legendary Gary Kasparov in favor
of ray ray andaru ray ray is chilling
and he has 30 seconds left Ray Ray is so
chill look at that if you were to tell
me with this California cool that Ray
has 10 seconds did you see his eyes
noing it's gone down right yeah it's 16
sorry no it's 10 right now 10 seconds
does he know that he only has five
seconds sure it's just a chill take it
easy guys uh after a twom minute thing
C 9 seconds for Ray and he's drinking
water what is he doing and he you have 5
Seconds move oh my God and then finally
a kind of a quick jolty jerky move
Knight D5 what about them apples taking
advantage of the pin Pawn on C4 and
eyeballing that gorgeous Square Knight
C3 check tactics on the board what just
happened can I play Queen
F3 yes I check my Fisher random
regulations completely
legal I guess you can play Queen
A4
yes you know Tit for Tat kind of thing
but eight seconds against four minutes I
don't think that that that is so imprac
say that Ray finds the perfect moves
when he has no time so right like if you
saw A3 D3 on the board you'd be really
reluctant to uh allow the mate one right
I mean oh my gosh incredible position
with no time by the way Gary is
completely winning sorry what Gary has a
winning move let's go to that one for
just a second see if he finds it and
then we can move on from it if he
findsen to D3 and the queen is on D3
that's winning so it's Bishop F5 Bishop
F5 is coming and I'm just picking up the
exchange at least
wow look at him he knows Gary looks like
he's uh he's licking his lips like
something good has happened he knows it
he smells it he tastes the victory right
now I spoke to
Sun well I mean but I'm going to go back
to the Hikaru game because that move
Knight D5 jump in on that move uh
Christian that move is a visual it's a
gorgeous looking move it's a visual yes
it keep some Advantage but not Queen a
how did Queen get to A8 I I think we're
having oh going have a pet we're going
to have a ended in a draw so let's
switch quickly to Gary and we'll let the
players figure out all of the missed
opportunities yep Gary's an exchange job
right now
it's Bishop F5 he's doing okay now he's
back only 20 second difference he's back
yeah okay uh one of the things that that
Gary's going to have to give up on is
this idea that he's going to Checkmate
because in fact uh Wesley's King is
super well uh protected King B2 King a
so you're not going to so you've just
got to win from the material perspective
and I was going to say Rooks belong on
open files so I was about to suggest
Rook E8 and Gary played the move F3
which I find a little bit uhan that is
very dangerous well the thing is he has
very simple way of dealing with this
Rook to D7 is one of them I really liked
Queen to D7 followed by by Rook to E8
and just Place everything on light
squares well it was a very funny moment
because the move D pardon me the move F4
F3 can't be prevented the only move I
saw as a threat was uh Queen E7 so Rook
E8 announce of prevention pound of cure
uh but Gary said no no no I'm not afraid
of your your queen infiltrating only one
check it's only one check check King
B7 so and and Wesley says okay Queen E6
King B7 King B2 so it's a waiting game
for Wesley Gary just needs to figure out
how to train pieces yeah no he just
wants to drop a rook on E2 once he can
play Rook uh E2 that's and he just
played Rook F7 with the idea to play
Rook E7 and Rook E2 precisely so yeah
there's no the problem is there's no
threats for white right you don't have
any way to get the Wesley trying
something he to push the pawn to A6 but
yes in almost a scotch defense a scotch
opening part you're a bit far away from
that yeah I think that black will
probably meet A5 with A6 and say you
know that's all you get I think this is
game over I don't see anything we might
actually just see the resignation right
there's also rookie one and Rook like so
many moves well the so for example Queen
G4 uh that's what I'm saying about just
give up the ideas of Checkmate is not
going to happen but it might happen but
Rook E2 Rook E2 that's a mighty powerful
pass pawn and Wesley down to 45 seconds
and this is the first time that Gary's
been up on
time in a Fisher random chess in like
forever I I want to see Gary's face
right now because you know he's feeling
it you know he's feeling it and by the
way he played Rook E7 E2 very quickly
and a nice spin at yeah little little
little twist at the end there twist he
looks pretty confident he sure does
heager uh Queen
H6 Rook E2 what happened A5 he's giving
up the root no you don't even think
about it I play
A6 I'm not allowing any uh tricky I
think you can easily take on F2 but and
he chose to don't take on
A6 who I'm a little bit surprised that I
mean A6 is such a five checkm coming
Rook F5 is is is
over be very Rook F5 Queen d8 but then
no queen d8 queen takes the8 good job
good job uh Gary said well I do see your
queen A5 Checkmate but I can block you
oh look at Wesley he's still throwing
the patties what about two yeah game
over ah what a start for Gary whoa
whoa nobody picked him and nobody picked
Gary no and Gary uh I think we're going
to see check made in just couple
moves uh sorry let me just refresh my
board I apologize be right back is
Perpetual threat I don't think so I
think the king is just like for example
Rook E7 I think the king could just run
right Queen D3 Queen D4 I'm not sure
what that does
but and another update Fabby did lose
against shankland he did lose it so with
the queen dominant on the Central File
Wesley resigned he could play Rook G7
threatening Rook G2 a comprehens a
comprehensive game by Gary literally
start to finish I think
Gary is is over the moon happy and we
were so critical of him that he was
spending too much time and and we were
right boy were we right let's jump to
the remaining game between Sam Sean and
leavon aronian it's a bishop versus
night ending classic which minor piece
is
stronger I think it's those G pawns
pawns that are really good uh so ason
answered in other words which uh which
piece is stronger we we do have King E2
on the board though no yeah King goes to
F3 that g Pawn
isn't apparently we're hearing that G3
was a mistake G3 now it's
equal but still anything can happen with
10 seconds on the clock for sure okay so
let's just imagine that after the move
Bishop H6 we would play King F3 right I
mean what could be well I was going to
say what could be more natural well 9 D3
not allowing king or King C5 maybe he
was afraid of uh King C5 to C4 Knight D3
on the board B5 and we can expect King
F3 Knight E1
wrong wrong why didn't he go King Sam's
playing really passively and now black
has an advantage on the queen side as
well oh
boy oh
boy clock clock yeah they both have 10
seconds 10 seconds so they're they're
both making mistakes with just
increments play well
somehow the bishop went from H6 to E5
with kind of a fortress for white
you tell me I'm not sure I was going to
say you don't want to play C4 as Leon
just played
C4 because you never want to play in
these position yeah that's the
commentator C cannot possibly Knight D1
can B4 be played well G4 I'll take it B4
I'll take it yeah you'll take it King C5
Knight C2 that stops B4 wait a minute
why is it white just doing very 3
seconds for Leon two oh
it's getting nerv nerve-wracking I don't
like this move King I we going to see
some repetition maybe would be surprised
Knight B4 I don't know now it's starting
isn't white that's what I'm saying isn't
it isn't it can pick up G3 Pawn isn't
White having the fun suddenly I think so
I think why having E5 oh sorry E5 King
B6 uh I was about to play E5 and King
takes G3 but don't go King B6 I this is
like a close position so white knight
can jump around and make it really
difficult for here it goes it's going to
be Knight B4 Knight F4 so I can go King
takes G3 right Knight D5 Knight
F4 I have Knight F4 and King takes G3
well Knight F4 the problem is I go B4
and you take on B4 I take on C3 and the
Knight is too far away so Sam is
actually playing to hold the position I
think he can hold it quite easily just
keeping the Knight there m I think he
wants he still wants to win the problem
is that whenever you take the Knight all
the way to the king side I go B4 and you
don't have enough time to come back got
he might be going for it well Knight
takes G3 could be on his agenda why not
once you play it I go B4 and I don't and
then I go back to
E2 Knight takes
G3 but then I go I think I go B3 I take
on A3 and then Bishop D6 you might lose
A3 Pawn ah so I'll take
on wait a minute you're risking you're
risking at that point yes I'm risking
you're risking yes with no time on the
clock oh two seconds for Sam
one he played the move with one second
on his clock now he played two fast
moves to gain some time did Sam Sam I
think it's time to uh accept it I think
Sam he wants to win he really want does
he have an opportunity Christian no no
no no no you cannot take on G3 is it
losing if he takes on G3 okay play then
move Knight because the king is on B6
you don't have B4 because of Knight D5
correct but he can't take on still you
cannot take on G you pinned yes he's
done it and here comes B4 he's done it
he's provoked the spawn sacrifices
Bishop takes C3 perhaps uh wait wait
take no I take a knight E2 and there's
Knight D4 check and Knight C2 what is
happening Knight Knight E6 to D4 wining
what is happening Leon for he just miss
that his King is on C6 oh my goodness he
missed KN D4 and he has blunder this is
over okay King D6 to E5 no King B6
Knight C1 no problem W KN C2 is forced B
E5 B5 now you have to worry also yeah
this is over B5 that's the winner put
the Knight on A1 way getting to it oh
what a cheapo by Sam well
done wow
wow I thought Bishop takes C3 in that
position so Bishop takes C3 was the
blunder uh Christian he could have
played A3 perhaps right King B7 at that
point was one of the moves just out king
B7 take advantage of the fact that the
Knight is pinned right wow but that
whole idea of Knight F4 and taking on G3
with the King was so tricky wow wow
that's good Lu finding that with 5
Seconds on the clock this is not easy he
he he was trying to gain some seconds
and work up the courage to play King
takes G3 and when he played King takes
G3 and right here I saw the move Bishop
C3 I thought white was lost right I mean
but at some point guys I have to take
you back a few moves because sure fact
Leon did not time this move and he
played it at some point this move C4
blocking the position as it was the
structure but he had this brilliant
opportunity at this point after the move
Knight to D3 first go C4 okay and now
what do you do if you go Knight to F4
then I do the same thing I go B4 right
now and the king is safe there's no
checks along the way the king is not on
C6 the king is not on B6 to give me
check with Knight coming to D5 or to D4
the king is on D6 you don't have a way
to approach uh the pawn and after Bishop
takes C3 A3 the pawn is Unstoppable
Unstoppable right so C4 golden
opportunity for him unfortunately he
didn't see it and if you do go with
Knight on B4 which I think would have
been the natural way of play in the
position the problem is right now I go
Bishop to H6 and perhaps this was the
blind spot that leevon did not spot
because after Bishop to H6 how do you do
it I'm threatening to go G2 you're
forced to take on G2 and then I take on
E3 I invade with the bishop Bishop lands
on C1
there's no way you're going to defend a
B2 pawn and after that everything falls
in the position you have to go Knight to
C2 right now right King to E5 and guess
what it's a Susan right you take on G3 I
take on e4 that's easy that's easy
that's very easy right so you have to go
Knight D4 and try to go corre for the B5
Pawn but once again it's all about G2 I
take or I take even on e4 I'm going to
defend this Pawn on C4 and then I'm just
going to start collecting your pawns on
the queen side beautiful but very
precise way of winning this position not
easy at all you have to spot the moment
Sam seon gets his first victory in the
tournament and he's a happy man right
now nice to win the first one as Gary
Kasparov knows as well so Nai sum up
this uh round for us if you don't mind
yeah we had three decisive results yeah
well let's take a look at the standings
in that case then we have Gary Kasparov
Sam Sean and Sam shenl leading the
tournament after the first round Gary
casparro fans take a photo their man is
on the top as it is Gary casparro versus
America
here nine great players and continue who
got the draw and we had two draws hikaro
Nakamura Drew against Ray Robson and
Jeffrey and lanir Drew in Berlin style
in Berlin style very safe draws three
players three of our Peaks Fabiano
Wesley and leevon currently sitting with
zero point Point well my Pi hikaro I'm
feeling I'm feeling actually pretty good
with with hiar and just to take a sneak
peek with the round two pairings we have
leonan playing Ray Robson Gary Kasparov
playing Hikaru Nakamura that's a big one
Jeffrey Jong against Wesley so Fabiano
against Dominguez that's a rematch of
the World Cup just played to Baku
continuing and two leaders playing each
other Sean against
Sam square and as we get prepared for
our our break let me just tell you about
what's happening at Q Boutique as uh we
I've got this beautiful uh t-shirt to
share with you favorite yeah sir stl.com
9lx unisex t-shirt this is the 2023
Edition it's perfect for any chess
player any chess player is going to find
they're going to like this 50% blend of
polyester 25% cotton and 25% rayon in
metallic ink screen printed shirt is
both comfortable and stylish and you
could actually see that t-shirt wor worn
by Fabby right now and I think lenier is
wearing it if I'm not mistaken so
they're they're both sty you have the
best models exactly it features the St
Louis chess club logo on the sleeve a
large print of the 9lx logo over the
back so you can look sharp both on and
off the chest not going on break
because we want to see yeah there you go
I mean he's showcasing uh and the St
Louis uh chess club on the sleeve the
last left sleeve there uh leavon
discussing his
game we didn't get to see how fabulos
this game but uh as Christian was
mentioning let let's just uh jump to
that because it was sort of like this
very strange position after the move
Queen B5 who could not play the move
Queen B5
uh Christian if you would bring up the
game on your board the game of Fabby the
game and the critical moments of this
game and I think we left it somewhere
around here and we were saying that
white is doing really well two Bishops
uh I believe it was this idea after
Queen to C6 Queen to C6 by the way was
not played for a very specific reason
that at some point you're always going
to have this opening of the bishop Pawn
H1 with tremendous consequences right
and in fact in this position if you go
F5 you cannot take because I'm going to
take back you're in trouble right this
is pretty much all she wrote game over
but he played the move C5 and in fact
the position is still really bad you
have a weak King two Bishops still this
beautiful Center for White and the
Knight on G4 despite the fact that he
has a beautiful Outpost it doesn't
really have a lot of targets it doesn't
do much on that beautiful outpost on G4
let's take a look at what happened
Bishop to A5 and by the way Sam was
really playing a good game very precise
game but unfortunately for him at some
point he played this move F5 critical
moment and I can understand why Fabby
did not play The Right Move which was
Rook takes C4 and then just go into this
end game it's a very depressing end game
because you take on G6 I take on D6 I'm
a pawn up there's absolutely no chance
you're going to win this position with
the black pieces you're going to have to
suffer for the remainder of the game
your king is still a bit weak you have
to find ideas of Bishop to E8 Rook to G4
doesn't really work because your king as
I was mentioning is quite weak and after
Bishop to E5 you're in trouble so from
afar this end game looks really really
bad busted and that's why he did not
play this he took on F5 but the problem
is once you allow these two pawns to
remain on the board they're going to
connect with each other and slowly
slowly get close to promotion and
unfortunately that's going to bring a
decisive advantage to White which he
dealt with quite precisely Bishop to F4
nice little tactic to end the game not
taking the Rook on E1 back but just
simply pinning the queen and winning the
game and we're going to have the reveal
of the next game's position in just a
few seconds let's take a look all the
players anxiously waiting uh for this to
happen as our uh Chief Arbiter Brian
Yang gets ready you know he's holding
Court he's got the power you know these
moments are to be Rel completely
randomized right it's just computer
button yes yes
exactly uh again I I think Faby and
leavon both uh sporting the Q Boutique
shirt I just okay all right spoke about
Leon and Fabi
yes I think Chris bird is sporting a
very impressive tie there matching with
the background right we talked about
that coming in on the
broadcast
and the players have the position we're
going to take a look at what they're
looking at right now as Nai spin spin
spin them Queen on A1 okay that's the
unfortunate piece that Bishop on B1 the
bishop on B1 can only be developed by C4
and or A3 to bring that Bishop out the
king looks good the Rooks look fine
Bishop on E1 is a bishop on both Bishops
I'm say are the bad pieces Pawn
weaknesses Knights are completely fine
they can go to F3 and C3 very quickly
yeah those are good uh Pawn weakness of
G2 well no not not bad and as the
players are looking uh we're going to
take a break we're going to have the
position so you can look and also I've
been told that Sabina foer had asked the
players a number of interviews uh and
we'll share some of those interviews
with you during the break see you soon
[Music]
absolutely hiar thank you so much for
joining me today in recent years you've
become um the most popular chess
streamer you've built up an amazing
audience you won the speed chess um
Championship so many times you are the
and you recently climbed up to world
number three uh what stands behind your
success
um I mean I I think uh obviously a lot
has changed in the last couple of years
I think certainly I found um something
that I enjoy a lot I think when you have
a lot of positivity in your life um and
you're very passionate about the various
uh projects that I'm working on I think
it certainly translates across the board
and I think as far as chess goes there
isn't a whole lot that changes I think
mostly it's about opening preparation
the amount of time you study and I think
I found a a very good balance between
being practical in terms of approaching
games a certain way and then also
studying uh when I need to but just
finding a finding the right balance I
think is more important than sort of
going over the edge and spending too
much time studying or spending your
entire life really just just worrying
about what other top players are doing
and it seems to be working
out and did you do something in
particular to prepare for this event um
no for this event I didn't do anything
to prepare I think uh with uh n 9lx 960
Fisher random chess
certainly uh for the most part it's
about the creativity at the board coming
with coming up with ideas right before
it begins just studying with other
players and so I don't think it's that
important I think perhaps there's
certain setups that even from having
played in the past I I have some idea of
where pieces belong but for the most
part it's Unique it's different and I
also think one big differen is on move
number one for the most part you can
play any move and I know when I played
here last year there there were a lot of
people studying some of us were studying
with other players some of us were on
our own like myself and oi Resa and um
and I think most games I try to do
something different than what everyone
else is doing and even then I think I
got decent positions so the fact that
you can play unique openings from the
start makes it quite different than uh
just classical normal chess and for for
that reason I I really do enjoy it and
you have 15 minutes to prepare for your
next game do how important are those 15
minutes for you to kind of get ready you
mentioned you might be doing it on your
own maybe you'll partner with someone
this year but yeah I mean I I think um
for the most part it's not super
important I think just having the first
couple of moves is is all that really
matters you know some events are like
here where you are on your own no
computer assistance some events you're
to use computer assistance I think in
both cases though the game is unique
pretty much as early as move number five
um no matter what I remember when I
played a match against Magnus some years
back where we were allowed to actually
get the position and and look at it with
computers and I remember even in that
match somewhere around move two or move
three already it was not what I looked
at or Magus looked at and so I think in
both cases it's going to be unique from
the start so it's more about just having
some general idea but mostly it's about
figuring it out once the game has begun
and what do you think is an important uh
type of exercise that people should do
or maybe that you do in order to improve
your visualization skills uh so this is
just about chest in general I think um
you know the biggest thing is doing uh
doing puzzles a lot of stuff has become
very commercialized over the last couple
years in particular and I think you know
some people look at like things like
puzzle rush for example as being
beneficial I actually would argue that
just doing puzzles without any of the
gimmicky stuff like timers or anything
else but just looking and and trying to
do puzzles SL tactics is arguably the
most important thing anyone can do um
because it's the one thing where there
is no pressure on you you can take your
time and figure it out whereas if you
are playing say games of Chess which is
another way of trying to improve um as
quickly as possible you can play you can
play games but you have to go back look
at the games try and understand and also
in the Split Second moments when you're
making decisions you aren't always going
to make the best decisions it's not
always replicable and so I think mainly
just doing doing puzzles nowadays of
course everyone does it online um
whether it's online whether it's from a
book but basically uh just um just just
doing puzzles SL tactics as much as you
can any blindfold Chess at all uh I mean
blindfold chess I think anybody below a
certain level cannot do it I I think
blindfold is is very good if you're
maybe expert level player 2,000 but if
you're below that I think it's
borderline impossible and I think
there's no no actual benefit from it and
I I know from personal experience um
that a lot of people who I who I know
who are in like the 1600 1700 rating
range they simply can't visualize they
can't do the sequences even when they
see the board in their head so I think
it's just not really productive at allow
level and of course you're known that
you've become a really strong player at
the beginning by playing a lot of bullet
chest um what do you enjoy the most
chess wise do you enjoy Blitz uh rapid
classical chess if you were to just pick
one what would be your the one yeah I
mean I think for me Blitz is my favorite
Blitz or what I would classify as like
Fast rapid so like 15 minutes with
10-second increment something like this
um slow rapid I don't particularly like
with 25 minutes I find it to be a little
bit too slow not fast somewhere in
between classical and Blitz um so
probably like the fast RP with 15
minutes or just Blitz like three 3 plus
1 or 3 plus 2 with the with the slight
increment final question for you hikaro
whom are you looking for the most to
play in this competition of of course
you've played probably everyone so many
times but is there a particular player
you're excited to play yeah I think I
mean for me playing against Gary is
always a great pleasure he's from a
different generation I think when when I
look at like myself Fabian Olan or
others I think we're we're often times
asked maybe not not so much in recent
years but in the past at least one of
the most common questions if you could
go back in time and play someone from
another generation who would you play
and I would say pretty universally at
least I think myself Fabiano and leavon
all pretty much answer the same way
which is we would love to have played
Bobby fiser and so I think considering
the gener generations that we're from
you know you always want to play people
who came before you they're the people
the idols that we all looked up to as we
were growing up and so playing Gary uh
is always very special even if he's not
as strong as he once was he's still
still one of the greatest players of all
time and having that opportunity I think
is very special and since you mentioned
F Fisher if you don't mind me asking one
one last thing he was uh he often said
how important the ability um of special
perception is in chess do you feel that
um what do you think is the most
important in chess 960 is it panel
recognition visualization is it the pawn
structure is there something specific
that I think one of the great things
about Fisher random is that the players
have to figure it out at the board and I
I would say it's not too different
actually if you look at just regular
chess going back say 150 or 200 years
now uh these days when we look you look
at Players like Paul morphe or some of
the early greats in chess we we tend to
think they were very good at the time
but they you know they don't hold up
against modern players but I think
certainly it's the exact same skill set
where back then you had to figure it out
now you have to do the same thing and
you know one of the things is that as
great as we are at regular chess there
still are a lot of blunders that that
occur um when you look at it with the
computers when we're playing each other
and so for that reason I think there a
lot of room to explore and I I think
generally the players who are more
creative I would say the players who
rely a little bit less on Preparation
tend to do better in 960 I would very
specifically refer to players like
Magnus who is great intuition myself and
probably Wesley so as well I think we're
we're players who of course we can do
preparation and we're we're very strong
players but I think our general feel is
is a little bit better in terms of the
intuition and unique way of looking at
looking at chess and I think that helps
us a lot in Fisher random thank you so
much hiar I wish you good luck and
looking forward to seeing you play this
tournament thank
[Music]
you the St Louis chess club will be
hosting its 13th annual charity golf
tournament on October 2nd at Glen eeko
Country Club this charity golf
tournament supports the club's
Scholastic chess initiative in providing
chess to over 100 schools in the St
Louis area to sponsor this event or to
enter your team please go to stou Lou
chess club.org and click on the events
tab that's the St Louis chess club 13th
annual charity golf tournament on
October 2nd at gleno Country
Club the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well well as high-profile tournaments
that attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership ship
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
world Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please please visit
World Chess h.org
[Music]
welcome back everyone we see players
analyzing the new position they got for
round two absolutely that's quite a
crowd of players there as they have been
hard at work prepping for uh this round
two and in round one our stand we had a
very eventful start welcome everyone to
our show as uh Nazi do the honors who
won current standings after round one we
have three Co leaders Gary Kasparov Sam
savan and Sam Shanklin uh two games
ended in a draw so we have four players
at half a point and in the round two
pairings coming up we've got uh well
I've got to say that Gary kaspar Caro
Nakamura match that's very exciting
Marquee right there but who else is
playing two leaders are playing each
other Sam savan and Sam Shanklin nice
Fabiano's playing lenier as you
mentioned it's going to be their a
second match in this month last month
right that they've uh played against one
another uh Fabi lanir in the
quarterfinals of the of the Baku World
Cup knockout but the two Sams are
properly speaking type of first that's
going to be our second the Gary kaspar
from hi Cara Nakamura notice that for
the
first uh round uh hikaro and Gary analy
together now that they're going to be
playing against one another get
lost and uh in this uh position
934 by the way I'm looking and and it's
uh
Wesley former opponents are now
analyzing there you go uh I see the
problem of the bishop BS the Bishops are
the ones the knights the Rooks the queen
that's okay but the bishop on E1 and the
bishop on B1 are you really okay with
the queen on A1 I am okay with the queen
on one like for example if you play C4
imagine
C4 imagine you got C4 and D4 both inh
like oo not B Knight C3 Bishop D3 the
queen could come to B1 and you could
battery on that diagonal you know what I
mean the Queen will find its path the
problem is imagine those moves I just
said C4 D4 Knight C3 what are you doing
with the bishop on E1 that's a real
problem that's awkward right so uh
that's what the players are facing as
well we're a minute or two away from the
start of round two Christian jump in uh
three three wins out of the five games
against these great competitors what
does that tell us that's rapid chess and
that's chess 9lx for you a lot of
decisive results because well first of
all again they've been analyzing but
only for 15 minutes they don't know
exactly how uh to improve their
positions early on and we've seen that
with Wesley getting a worse position out
of the opening uh lener and Jeffrey
found a way to that Berlin chess 9lx end
game but uh that was about it we've seen
a lot of imbalanced positions out of the
openings and this is the trademark of
Chess 9x mhm there you see uh leavon
with the white pieces against very big
smiling Ray Ray Ray has two BLS in a row
right the unfortunate pairing he will
finish with white in the tournament yes
but he will be handicapped by a four to
five inbalance and he had the winning
position against saru with that yes he
did well he just had five seconds on the
clock well that was the thing at the end
when he played Knight D5 was that the
winning position
still no no at that point it wasn't 95
threw away some of his Advantage I think
at that point he had a slight Advantage
but to be honest I think the most
practical decision was to take the draw
because with 5 Seconds 0.8 I believe it
was an advantage you're not going to
feel that right and you are very prompt
making big mistakes which would lead to
disastrous situations by the way
handshakes and we saw a very determent
looking Gary in the board right I mean
wow uh really focused and we have first
and we have liftoff C2
C4 uh I think that's a very uh
reasonable and practical opening here
for white the bishop on B1 already uh if
white could get in moves like C4 D4 E4
grabbing the center opening up the
bishop and equally so a good uh reaction
by black yes and as white I would very
very much Aspire uh to playing moves
like E3 and D4 which would uh open up
this bishop on E1 uh for easy
development it's quite interesting
because we were seeing on the analysis
board they were analyzing B4 at move one
Gary and Wesley and Gary just said no no
forget about our analysis I'm just going
to go C4 c44 as a that's what they were
looking at yes C4 A5 and then C4 I think
it was what they were analyzing but now
we have C4 C5 Knight F3 I like the way
things are developing it's all about
that Queen on A1 right and we know that
it's going to be all about those Queens
in the corner how are you going to open
those without creating any structural
problems I think this is very practical
as well B2 B3 again a Prelude uh for
prepping D4 uh when I can play D4 and
Bishop C3 Nazi then I you ask me what am
I doing with the queen on A1 suddenly I
feel pretty good
about the queen on A1 if I can get my
Bishop to C3 andaru you think white
should play D4 quite early yes like now
now would be my choice please Ray hasn't
made the move
yet well we know Ray is a thinker but on
move one it's move one Ray I know you're
trying to analyze the position but it's
move one D4 and a full uh stop um that's
a couple of minutes I think if if I'm
not mistaken maybe you can see the clock
yes Y 2 minutes yeah two minut two
minutes come on R that's 10% of your
allocated time right you're going to
spend on one you know there's this
famous uh video that's been circulating
online of uh I believe uh vishy vishy
against ianu if I'm not mistaken when
vishy spent about 3 minutes of his five
minutes in a Blitz game at move one or
two right and then he went on to M Ian
but it was a very interesting moment and
it's very similar sure the stakes are
different but it's very very similar to
this one it was something like that by
the way just to he's still thinking he's
still think and he doesn't look like
he's ready even after two and a half
minute think to his move Ray wake up by
the way same thing lanir against also
Frozen do you think Len lanir and Ray
work together the start of thisch and
they didn't look at D4 they didn't look
at D4 I'm thinking after I'm seeing D4
let's get down to business B6 C5 let's
go just like not the best move is that
why there why is D4 so shocking I it
it's one of the best moves and
finally I think he played C5 yeah I was
about to say
B6 risk move you're bringing your Rook
out on move two which is why I might
have been more inin to play R make a
move not yet Ray is still thinking are
you kidding me no but this is
unacceptable yeah it's true Ray wake up
make a move c c they both came up with
the same idea and by the way both fabbi
and leavon practically speaking they
recaptured they captured on C5 instantly
as if they had prepared this yeah whoa
let's jump back to the game of Gary and
hikaro for a moment because those
players have played more moves and Gary
did play the move E2 E3 I was more or
less suggesting well I was suggesting
the immediate D4 with the idea that in
case of takes takes uh White is ready to
play B Bishop C3 uh one of the beautiful
things about capturing Scandinavian oop
excuse me Scandinavian defenses are
really really good when you can't play
moves like Knight C6 and Knight E6 the
queen is actually superbly uh placed in
the middle of the board so you would not
want to capture on D4 uh twice uh but E2
E3 a Prelude to E5 you know I think we
had uh early D4 in a very similar
position in two Sams games two Sams
board five Sam squared Sam squared there
we go and by the way here we do see uh
uh the precise idea right just a
different move later right Knight and
Bishop E3 Queen
B8
H3 and we've caught up to the players
White's position I do to I mean uh
players will who like the moroy bind
will be familiar with ideas of Knight E4
and Knight E3 the black Bishop on E8 is
just terrible it really is you're going
to have to play D6 and Bishop D7 at a
certain moment um in time and okay very
very nice uh Jeffrey Jang Wes Leo let's
just take a quick Gander at that one
this is similar setups in three games
with C4 and
B3 um it's like one of those moments I I
had to just pause for a moment because
it looks like an absurd move uh
96 yeah well I mean this idea of Knight
F4 right like you know so it's not so
that easy you know to defend this Pawn
on E2 it's a little bit award play
Knight C3 yeah unfort that is a good
move of course but it is kind of funny
to see a move like Knight F4 and then
this inability to defend upon on E2 okay
we're going to keep uh our Marquee
matchup Gary uh versus Hikaru as our
boards and the Sam squared as both Sam
svon and Sam Shanklin won uh their first
round uh matchups and they share the
lead with Gary and I think uh Fabiano
and leevon have very similar positions
after we had D4 and C5 in both of their
boards yeah with C D4
C5 and but no A4 on oh pardon me that's
the wrong board um A4 for Fabby Fabby
played the move A4 and uh leavon is
still
thinking yes but they have pretty much
the same position R this is a leavon ray
do we like the Rook on C5 I do not I do
not like early developments Rooks in the
openings especially early openings tend
to be the most clumsy of pieces if
they're not getting themselves trapped
and captured uh you normally speaking is
very dangerous to have so let's try to
understand this move
A4 we've discussed that taking space
Advantage is important but what else
because after A4 it felt like B6 should
be the move to make was he concerned
perhaps by Queen A3 and Bishop B4 so
this was the plan yes maybe it it it it
does look
artificial pardon me Knight comes to C6
exactly well it that was why he
retreated as Rook I think he was really
eager to play the move Knight C6 maybe
he was a little bit concerned again that
The Rook could potentially get trapped
so he played Rook to C8 as Prelude
I mean especially if you were to play
Queen A3 I would be playing Knight C6 to
defend E7 or Bishop D6 Bishop to D6
Bishop
B4 but the move A4 I don't quite fathom
that one Christian again the idea is
very obvious just go Queen A3 Bishop to
B4 and also take away that B5 Square for
the bishop because sometimes you would
like to go Bishop to B5 to attack that
pawn on E2 is not that easy if you uh
see the position to defend that pawn on
E2 unless you have the move Knight to D4
which certainly you have it in uh most
instances but that's why he played the
move A4 he lost in my opinion an
important Tempo and I would have played
Knight E3 follow it up with C4 and try
to put as much pressure in the center as
possible right now he's following it up
with Knight to E3 maybe a little bit too
late still the position is very very
complex pretty much equal at this point
anything can happen it's all about those
Bishops how do you get them out the
queen why Queen already out black queen
still you have a couple of ways to uh do
so you can go Bishop D6 and put it on
the B8 H2 diagonal or you can just
simply go B6 and open it uh it up via
the long diagonal a lot of options for
both players again it's all about the
time right now and lener has been
spending so much on move one he spent
four minutes on move one what is Ray
doing right now well let's uh I just
wanted to make a comparison
between uh leavon and Ray and well we
haven't seen The Rook Retreat quite yet
Castles by white no A2 A4 by leavon and
I I frankly would prefer to use that
Tempo uh otherwise C4 later exactly uh
C4 uh with ideas of Knight E3 just as uh
uh Christian was advising I'm going to
jump back to Gary and Hikaru as Gary has
achieved his aim which was to play the
move D2 D4 and in this particular case
recapture with the pawn yeah unless Caro
can play D5 immediately let's take a
look D5 Knight
E3 since I'm already castled I'm really
eager to play what we might call the
hanging pawns right with uh Queen on A1
it's yeah so strange it is strange but
boy it it's it's lurking yeah right it's
it's D4 D5 and Gary could be in his
element and we know Gary uh throughout
his entire career proved himself time
and time again to be the
most fantastic attacking player you
don't really want to give him his free
flowing element Christian uh Jump Right
In uh Hikaru did by the way play the
move E7 E6 and trying to take a stand in
the center feels like some isolated
Queen Pawn kind of positions what do you
think no absolutely white has that
typical slight Edge in the position this
symmetrical potentially symmetrical
structure if you do take on D5 and we
see those uh D pawns facing each other
but one thing that strikes me as odd a
little bit if you would have told me
that Gary will be up 3 minutes after the
first 10 moves I wouldn't have believed
you against CaRu the fastest probably
fastest player one of the fastest
players on the planet so um this is
definitely an encouraging sign for
Gary's game and for Gary's tournament so
definitely in good shape with some good
chances in this one and imagine what a
fulminant start two would be yeah I
think Gary just came in with a lot of
confidence after that first game sure
and then with white pieces maybe you
don't have to spend as much time
deciding development as you do with
black nothing nothing is better in the
life of a chess player than starting
with a victory except two Victory vict
uh quick question for you I'm looking at
the bishop on B1 I'm not
satisfied but I I am drawn to this idea
of Bishop F5 so the move C4 takes
D5 I find rather attractive if you
recapture with a pawn and you know or
you could take with the Knight we'll
look at that in just a moment I'm going
to take a The Rook I'm just going to ask
The Rook where yeah exactly but then
you're going to give up the only uh the
the open file in the position right and
let's say after uh Rook d8 I'm I'm I'm
trying to
extend the diagonal of my queen so in
other words if I could induce you to
play captures captures ah now now you
can see my sneaky uh ideas of Bishop C3
and E6 I'm feeling the trend is Gary's
friend here uh Christian am I getting
this right the C4 takes D5 give Gary
that's the typical advantage that you
will get in the symmetrical structure
slight pressure still nothing
extraordinary you're not winning by any
stretch of the imagination but you have
a better position you will still have to
prove it um far away from any decisive
result this is going to be a long game
and there's going to be chances on both
sides but this one is hitting up the
Wesley so with the black pieces against
Jeffrey Shong and take a look at this
Pawn sacrifice Castle C4 C uh C5 Knight
F3 Knight to F6 we've seen this start B4
castle by the way B5 and B5 beautiful
interesting Pawn Sacrifice from Wesley
Knight to F4 he's playing for the
initiative Knight F4 right yeah don't
take Bishop to E5 beautiful move right
and this is the plan be behind this move
B5 I'm going to pin the Knight and you
cannot touch the bishop in the center
Knight takes C5 would be met by Queen
takes G2 whoops that's game over in one
go so don't do that don't touch the
bishop on E5 but what else what are you
going to do I have white defend E2 Pawn
very good question n yes absolutely
that's the key idea behind and the
answer is Bishop D3 is the only way
right that's so ugly yeah it's an ugly
move but do you want to take I'm not
sure if this helps you too much because
you're G first of all I'm still a is the
time and you're losing some tempies
right you have to move the bishop back
or defend it then I have D4 ideas so
Knight takes D3 perhaps not the best
move but how would you continue right
now maybe just the simple D6 D6 and
saying okay you put your Bishop on D3
what are you going to do with the bishop
on E1 now no more D3 Bishop to D2 you
haven't gotten to that stage of this
position yet so perhaps a very
intriguing I have to say Pawn
sacrifice crazy game in this one but
Wesley I really like what he's doing
well that is certainly mixing it up and
we do see 13 minutes to again about 13
minutes as you see these two uh
tournament active tournament Players uh
keep looking for a strong comeback after
the first loss yeah actually really like
H5 H4 H3 for black what I mean with the
Knight on F4 wow very ambitious on the
king side uh H5 H4 H3 very
aggressive what on Earth that white oh
White Castle so that inspired uh that
okay but uh one of the things I was
going to ask is check this out as an
idea Bishop to D3 and Christian threw
out the move D6 and said okay then I was
going to throw out the move Bishop C4
which looks crazy it does because but I
do have the idea of e3 you want it as an
in between move if I play D5 I wanted to
take your can you Bishop if I could
takes now there's no Queen takes G2
according to my right according to my
rule book and now I didn't know uh did I
want to come back with a knight or
possibly just block the diagonal and
maintain my knight intriguing right just
it's a funny move Bishop to D3 to C4 uh
just to get out of the way of Knight
takes F4 again I just want to drop in on
our Marquee matchup as Gary Kasparov is
going up against car Nakamura nothing
happened this is where we're saying
Gary uh previous additions of Fisher
random this is where he gets himself
into trouble and then he works himself
up up because he does get good positions
which he
absolutely uh destroys in a frenzy of
time trouble well I think right now it's
a critical moment in his game and he's
deciding if he should take on D5 or not
it's not worth 10 minutes on the clock
though to make that decision you should
you should make that decision rather
quickly because we know more questions
are going to be asked in the game in the
future well nothing happened in the ray
game the only thing that happened is
raised down to his last seven minutes
his last seven minutes seven
minutes those guys need to work together
he's been spending his whole time on not
natural moves sure but the first few
moves of the game I mean you're going to
have so many other issues along the way
and look at this spe things up speed
things up right leavon is is in Act is
in a rapid chest ear leavon just got up
and took a walk and said let me go take
a a look at these games Ray Ray's still
in only made five moves nothing has
happened yet I mean five moves and he's
used 13 minutes terrible terrible
terrible time management don't know
what's going on in Ray's head uh let's
check in on the Sam squared um you
really like that sound i' love that I
mean look dude I'm going with your
podcasting uh with uh fa and Christian
uh here we have G7 G6 on the board and I
visually to
me Sam Shanklin black has done
everything right because this looks like
a very good well Dragon
slash um as long as you're not concerned
about King side the king safety because
there's no pieces around black king just
one Bishop which can easily be exchanged
right maybe some aggressive F4 is coming
and G5 and uh on the H file possibly F7
F6 I I view that as the type of move I
can always play I'm much more inclined
in such positions uh to try to to play
B5 but I think F7 F6 is actually a
Prelude to playing the move B5 normally
speaking in a maroy bind where we have
this uh what is it the accelerated
Dragon positions black is often times
playing moves like A6 and B5 and white
is often trying trying to white let's
play A4 you play A6 I'll play
A5 and that's why she gets paid the big
bucks uh okay that's that that's exactly
right by the way that I mean that would
be my Approach as well because I am
thinking whatever I do nurse operations
on the king side I can do it on my
timing and stop yeah just stop the
counter playay Christian jump in What
what you got well Fab is uh looking to
bounce back in this one he has a pretty
golden opportunity because take a look
at what happened and it does seem like
this move d4 at move one is the more
challenging option for white most
challenging option for white and Rook to
C8 I have to say to my eyes is a bit too
passive Rook to C5 Rook to C8 you're
losing too many tempies and you're going
to have to pay for them Knight to C6 C4
very important to play fast with the
white pieces you have to find the
weakness you have to open up the
position take advantage of the fact that
you have those extra tempies and this is
exactly what Fabiano is doing Knight to
F5 with some tempies in the position try
to attack the pawn on E7 and if you do
give me the two Bishops the bishop on D3
beautifully placed already to try to uh
attack the pawn on H7 and potentially
hint at some ideas against the black
king Knight to E7 Bishop to B4 Knight to
D5 Bishop to A3 and right now I have to
say I'm looking at the position I'm
seeing this move E4 coming at some point
Maybe not immediately but at some point
E4 attacking Knight on D5 the
Superfluous Knights on D5 and E7 two
Bishops for white an open Center The
Rook ready to go to H4 or G4 to create
some mating attack the queen is
perfectly placed on A1 completely
winning position right now for Fabiano
and the engine approves the engine is
saying plus four right now plus four not
a single Pawn up but I'm plus four in
this position because you simply don't
have moves and as you can see from from
the time expenditure as well lenier is
not happy with what he has in front of
his eyes any we have rookie eight sorry
I think it's plus4 because black is
playing without their Queen exactly yes
well that would make it plus nine uh by
my count but boy plus four I would have
never guessed it that high one of the
things that I I really enjoy about
Fisher random is you've got this random
position at the start that becomes less
and less randomized and you don't see
this often but this Bishop on D3 is
actually protected by a Pawn on E2 which
is great because the bishop on D3 blocks
the D file and you get to play Rook
C1 in Wesley's game I don't know if
Jeffrey blundered the pawn or gave it
back but E2 Pawn is
gone with a hak casito as well so
Jeffrey never played Bishop D3 that we
were looking at he played King H1 he
played King H1
invited uh Wesley to capture the pawn
I'm sure he was thinking about Knight
takes E5 here wasn't he Knight takes E5
but the Rook on C1 okay let's go now
where's your knight oh o B3 then D4 very
play
A4 oh oh oh oh so maybe A4 was just a
big mistake that's that's strange no but
maybe he felt that he didn't want to
play Bishop D3 and uh Wesley's B5 Gambit
can we call it the Wesley Gambit it's
paid off yeah I think he's the first one
to do it Wesley Gambit now Wesley Gambit
I mean take pride position which
one Wesley's Gambit Wesley's gamb
256 yes what position
934 uh 934 wle G remember this
right immortalize it make your book uh a
bestseller well there's so much more
ground to find uh good ideas right name
them in fact last night we were playing
Bug House and the conversation with
Fabby and leavon and Benjamin Bach
Christian myself was chess opening names
and how
obscure a lot of these names are and
nobody knows and then you have people
like leavon and Magnus who are
contributing
enormously to the E explosion of opening
Theory and what's a
opening give me you know and he's he's
introduced he's smiling why right why is
he smiling who
smil Ray is laughing Ray is laughing
what the heck has he done he's not I'm
not sure if he's he's or not perhaps uh
Bishop E4 somehow got a big smile out of
uh Ray I think he just simply missed it
he missed it yes yes he missed it and
actually pretty bad situation it's one
of those things that Knight takes E4
we've seen this movie before Queen lands
on G7 or G2 and that's Checkmate so the
move Bishop E4 takes advantage of the
pin Knight by the way uh leavon is
eyeballing an opportunity here of
capturing and capturing on E7 sorry n
sorry can we jump back to Wes's game
because there's another sacrifice or
blunder Knight takes G2 happened what
what king G2 is he going to play G5 and
get the Knight back well you wanted to
play H5
H4 uh I like G5 I like Bishop D7 he
played Bishop to D7 and he's slow
playing the sacrifice can he get away
with that that Black Knight has been the
star of this game Knight F4 Knight takes
E2 then
G2 uh just a second guys are you
believing this I'm how do you defend the
B the let's go D4 okay I'll take that
Bishop H3
check that one I didn't plan on Bishop
H3 okay I'll have to readjust relocate
my jaw after Bishop H3 check oh this is
actually completely over this is
actually completely over after B7 I was
expecting Bishop
G4 Wesley's Gambit is winning in style
oh my goodness that would be kaputsky um
wow
um help me out on this one Christian how
there is no help coming in this one I
was afraid of Bishop G4 but Bishop
H3 is a smack no you have to give the
peace back with Knight to E4 but that's
not going Knight I'm losing my
Queen Bishop E4 I guess that's what you
have no maybe bishop Bishop to E4 yes
but after Knight takes for is kind of
the same
situation well thanks for that I
mean I I refer to Christian is not my
Ace in the Hole but my Deuce of
Clubs Bishop E4 Knight takes E4 that
looks horrifying I mean it's the only
way to prolong the agony but that's
that's that's just Agony that's not
happening Bishop D7 just brilliant so
much better than G5 it really looks
great uh leavon aronian and Ray Robson
after the move Bishop E4 big smiles
laughter from Ray as he realizes he has
just fallen for a sucker punch he played
the move Queen D7 and leavon is tempted
by how do I make attacking ideas uh like
Bishop C6 and Knight E7 work um he can
play Rook F to D1 first that's I invite
everybody toly what Ray wants though
no no no no I'm going to sacrifice you
do I just want to sacrifice I just want
to free my pieces a little bit maybe
that or maybe Queen takes D1 first but
yes something along those
lines and by the way the clock times are
so decisively in lon's favor 11 minutes
for leavon a Mir 2 and a half for Ray
and a bad position I love your move Rook
D1 why didn't that occur to me Christian
doesn't no I like it I I like it I just
think that this is what Ray hopes to
achieve just to get something some sort
of play in the position by the way with
white you can just simply play the move
Bishop to A3 and then go Rook to D1 and
there's still nothing stopping that plan
unfortunately you cannot Castle it's the
E7 Square E7 and E2 we've seen these two
pawns getting under tremendous pressure
remember what Wesley did Knight to F4
that E2 Pawn was in big trouble the
whole wesle Gambit is based against that
pawn on E2 that's the weakness in the
position Pawn he took a d these players
understood that yeah very very nice I
want to go to Gary Gary spent 10 minutes
seriously it's it's on one move it's
unprecedented and he's done it he's done
it in previous editions of the 9lx and
it's and it he gets burned by it every
time I mean he knows better and he says
it to himself I have to be more
practical now he's down to 4 and 1 half
minutes uh almost a 2 to1 time advantage
against uh Hikaru and by the way it
looks like a pretty normal position
they've instead of random they've
normalized the position my first
impression is even Queen Gambit or
exchange slav or something yeah right
and it shouldn't be where is a two to
one time advantage in one of the players
favor on the other hand it's not that
difficult to play with white so maybe
time disadvantage won't play a big role
exactly Queen uh we did see Gary playing
very quickly Queen B2 just defending the
bishop and uh yeah again I if not for
the clock I would call the position
balanced by the way that was a strange
decision to trade dark squared Bishops
help me out on this one yeah because at
the end of the day right right at the
end of the day you've left yourself with
a D5 pawn and a D7 bishop and how can
that be good for uh the second player I
think he's just trying to simplify the
position and he made more space he
created more space specifically for his
Queen so right now you can go Queen to
D6 it feels like sure I understand the
long-term Advantage strategical
advantage that white possesses right now
but the material is still very limited
and I have active pieces now that my
queen is out okay fair Queen D6 can
should I play
B5 yeah let's just have a a look see CU
if I kick your knight out then maybe I
get E5 Square I have a feeling guys Ray
is going to resign let's jump to the ray
maybe we should go to that one just
because it's so bad it's so hopeless I
mean he played Bishop A3 by the way
raised down to his last 20 seconds and
there's just nothing to do absolutely
nothing uh Rook D1 Queen's going to be
harassed and he can't even give up he
can't even give up his Queen for a rook
and a a minor as you were pointing out
we and only chess 9 Alex you can see top
players losing 11 moves yes cuz Jeff is
also losing right against Wesley it's
also been only 12 moves or something
yeah and and it's remarkable how many
Miniatures of literally a dozen moves
you can see H7 H6 so essentially Ry is
saying if I am forced to play the move
Queen E6 I don't want to get hit with a
knight G5 on my head n seconds for Ray
leavon said look I'm a pawn down five I
will three o6 and he barely made it how
many seconds does he have seven seconds
so he made his move with two seconds on
his clock but again terrible
terrible just continue attacking on so
many levels uh Rook a pardon me Rook on
F1 to C11 yes you know putting as much
pressure on a pin piece as possible uh
looks to me must be winning so the idea
of H6 was obviously to prevent the move
Knight to G5 yes it was all about
stopping Knight G5 have at least some uh
breathing room with that Queen on E6
right yeah but after Rook C1 I mean so
hopeless yeah just go ahead and kill me
me if I go
G6 I I I don't C7 if you're asking
nicely very nice that that is boy did I
walk into that
one you had a good night sleep last
night didn't you I mean you came to you
came to the studio ready to rock and
Rumble and roll uh no this is this is uh
I'll resign on being I felt like an
ultimate moves by the way there
was uh certainly I wanted to reach in
and to resign for one of the players by
the way Jeffrey did had a very quick win
by Wesley South 13 moves and Wesley
bounces back and he got an opening named
after
him and by the way after this great move
Bishop D7 Bishop D3 was played I was
thinking Bishop H3 check Bishop G4
Bishop E2 Knight H4 and Jeffrey said Yu
I've had enough I've seen enough Knight
is dropping in on F4 terrible terrible
things are happening uh to White's
position he gave it a rest let's jump
back to leavon and Ray because ry's got
like 7 seconds on his clock in a
terrible position uh Nazi just crushed
me when I made a suggestion of G7 G6 so
it's not good I don't see anything and I
don't even know why uh leavon is
thinking a rook F1 plays itself make his
last move pretty much because after Rook
C1 Ray might as well resign resign
there's not much in it it's it's it's
that bad back to Gary Kasparov andaro
Nakamura as Gary did win a
pawn wow interesting your B5 by the way
happened it occurred Knight E5 Knight C4
so it was a sacrifice it was a sacrifice
and Gary said don't mind if I do and
he's a up I mean certainly when the
bishop comes to E6 and the pawn on D4 is
under a lot of pressure I I I will say
that black
has good compensation to say it's
sufficient that would be maybe an
overstatement fobby laner getting wild
what's happening in fobby there was a
peace sacrifice whoa so Lan's up a piece
but up for two PS
and takes takes smack smack that's two
pawns check
check um Knight to F5 is the move that
we see on the board wait a minute Knight
F5 on the board so that's inviting an E4
right all right let's let's see what
what's happening if I do go E4 well the
the question I was having for myself is
should I should I include H6 well we'll
find out in a moment let's let's start
with E4 and see where this leads needs
say are we missing something what is
looking really strong ah maybe Knight
C3 Knight C3 Queen E1 yeah that doesn't
really help that much uh I have a a
weird I'm not sure the bishop on A3 is
what if I just move my
Rook uh
C5
okay
what is happening I don't know I'm
confused by what's taking place the
intention I suppose is that is really
deep that is really deep if this
happens uh W the
players night F5 inviting E4 that is is
is great and I have to show respect for
our two tournament leaders Sam Sean and
Sam shankland uh let's just jump to this
one because because well we left it at
F6 and I just surprisingly it's Sam
Shanklin who is attacking on the H file
remember earlier I suggest that white
should have an attack yeah but not only
that not only is he attacking he's got a
pawn in this pocket as well so he's he's
attacking from a position of strength is
Sam Shanklin H5 H4 uh reading your your
your your thoughts from the previous
game uh this looks great I've got one
weakness sufficiently covered for black
you think white should pick up A7 Pawn
just to at least not be down Pawn yeah
but the problem is you go Queen A7 and
you're right you know if you're going to
suffer you know you don't want to suffer
down material but are we surviving this
checkmating attack that's coming down
the H file well some played C5 didn't
take on D4 A7 he did play
C5 okay he say too open up the position
exchange exactly not get he would love
any trade so that he could in this case
be threatening E7 but it's all about
this H3 move right which is I'm already
played I mean if you take on D6 I'll
recapture this Rook is actually
pinned in fact it's Tethered to uh the
defense of G2 so C5 H3 I don't even see
how C5 actually helps White's cause
really good for for Sam Sam Sam shankin
uh could be starting with two out of two
yes Fab's winning I don't know exactly
how Ray is still alive is Ray still
alive somehow he hasn't resigned yet how
did Ray survive this he did he has
survived he just hasn't resigned yet
takes takes that's a discovered check so
he's a pawn down King on
D7 I think uh and by the way he looks
absolutely disgusted with the position I
you can see it on his face he's like and
he as he should be and we do have a
result as Fabby bounces uh back with a
win over lanir um there was this great
comment by uh leavon during ultimate
moves it was like white has the two
black has the two Bishops and an active
King think King was exposed right so in
this position you know Rays upon down
but he has the active
King it's not a good look yeah I think
think he's about Ray is just when should
I resign should I resign this moment the
next moment he's laughing about it and
something he's finding amusing Queen E4
and thank you very much it was nice
knowing you three decisive games as
we're going to jump to Gary and uh Gary
kaspar F Naru Nakamura the two stams are
still at hard work as well well this is
where Gary's an extra Pawn but is it
mean about to get his Pawn back is it
that simple uh supposing I play the move
Rook to C7 I balling A7 so in other
words if you take on C D4 I was going to
trade he play Gary played Rook C8
something similar but not exactly Queen
takes D4 now right well that's a draw
offer I would
say yeah and he's to half a minute half
a minute against four and a half yeah
give me back the 10 minutes I used I
would say this is a draw for because
black is slightly better maybe oh for
sure yeah no those pawns on the queen
side on light squares those are going to
be easy pi and the problem is you cannot
get your Rook active with Rook to C7
because that invites Rook D1 yeah you
got to be very very careful that uh the
The Rook does not like it would be very
desirable from White's perspective to
play a move like Rook to the seven to go
but this is where things could go
instantly wrong and that was why we saw
A3 well this Pawn Sacrifice by Hikaru
just turned out to be genius I mean
because it solved his problems okay F3
and uh very comfortable end game for
Hikaru and no question about it Gary has
to defend this very passively which is
not his favorite thing to do no he is
not
it is limited M material however so I
would still say the most result is a
draw right but Hikaru is pressing for
sure right and Gary I like this move F3
by the way yeah not only is Gary
uncomfortable but we are seeing that
head shaking as Gary is saying to
himself Gary is saying to himself dude I
was a pawn
up now I'm defending a slightly worse
position you know
what's going
on and back to two Sams the two Sams two
Sams yeah shank has a lot of pressure on
the king side as a consequence of H3 we
saw the move Queen E3 by Sam Sean like
this is an amazing wow that's being
tactically alert that's staying that's a
very nice move 15 seconds and counting
for Sam heavan as he's under 10 seconds
in this move E5 is a stunner he's still
not ready to move and he's down to 2
seconds and there it goes oh wow with
one second one
second whoa I think time stopped there
for a it did it did and boy did he
forget about his clock because that was
a stunning move three was not a good
move no it wasn't and the move why by
the way Sam Shanklin played H3 takes
G2 and he had opportunity there for
queen3 Queen H4 was also an option there
was a lot he he used almost no time on a
position where he had so many nice
attractive opportunities uh Queen takes
Rook takes Bishop uh Rook takes G2
pardon me hitting the bishop and now we
have both Bishop F5 as well as F6 takes
F5 to consider 1 minute 50 seconds
against 12 seconds same color Bishop
endgame and wait wait a minute ah
there's Rook E1 check at the end but
there is Bishop takes Tak convinced I'm
not convinced maybe think G6 by the way
uh meeting Sam uh
Shanklin at the opening C ceremony for
this event he said to me yeah sir you're
not going to believe it but it took me 3
years I've just finished my book on Rook
endings well guess what
Sam good for you because you're in a
rook
ending just in time just in time does he
have enough to win
this
uh first impressions are yes because
Black's King is so very nicely place but
the double pawns double Pawns in them
good I I I don't see it you go on the E
file I give you a check on E7 you go on
the G file I give you a check on G7 so I
start with a check of
course right King F3 and I give you
another check King F2 back and I'm
playing
F3 but how do you improve how do you
make progress well we start with the two
checks they they're repeating your going
for it it's going for it that's because
these guys are very
good they're the best they're the best
they're the best ever are we going to
see F3 he's reaching for it and he's
done it okay so did you already read
Sam's book no is that why you're
guessing I'm telling you I didn't even
get an advanced copy he said that it's
going to the printer I said okay Sam uh
you got a
sale uh I'll speak with him and he'll
give you the 5% family right the family
discount oh that was a good move by Sam
SE isn't this just over like a draw Rook
A4 that stops the king from I guess you
can play F5 F4 and then King G4 at that
point I've got Rook C4 in my pocket why
did he go by the way R to E4 Rook to E3
yeah no this must be a drawn position
now I I feel that uh yeah okay and a
draw GRE okay quickly let's go to the
remaining game of Gary Kasparov andaru
Nakamura the two Sam split at the point
that means they're standing at one and a
half and Gary
Kasparov needs a draw in a difficult POS
well difficult is maybe strong it is
quite difficult isn't there also Bishop
C4 option oh gosh I'm afraid of Rook E2
and Bishop C4 but you're absolutely
right this is
scary and Gary down to 15 seconds
against
34 yes and there he and
Gary Gary's calculated King and pawn end
game what did he calculate is this a
draw I'm not so sure okay you go there
you go C5 A4 because he's thinking King
D4 King E5 is Gary okay King B5 King D4
King A4 King E5 King takes A3 King takes
F5 B5 King moves and then B4 F5 it's
actually wow if King doesn't go to
G6 isot I'm going to promote with a
check on f8 cuz King CU you your king is
going to be on A3
nicely calculated by they they're
following your analysis uh for really
good
calculator by the way you what am I
standing in mud or something you guys
are calculating all the good moves it's
impressive and there you have it King
takes A3 King G6 just go to G6 G6 not G6
because of
B1 he's looking so he's he's kind of
like King E5 or E6 King E5 or King E6
his little finger uh situation I don't
need I don't need to be there do a draw
or check still playing check and by the
way all of those moves have given
Gary giving Gary a lot of time he's a
showman yeah he's a showman as giving
Gary a lot of time to uh with the with
the 5-second increment to increase his
minute on the clock
and Gary's very pleased with that save
that was a nice piece of King and end
game calculation yes how much of that
you 15 seconds on the clock wow wow
impressive stuff he still got it he
still got it we have another three
victories we started the tournament with
three out of five victories we're still
maintaining that 60% decisive uh score
as we will
have three players still tied for first
yes I don't think standings have changed
although leavon did leavon maybe leavon
join the first game fordon me I stand
corrected so they all bounced back
Wesley bounced back leevon bounced back
fa bounced back as well and take a look
at how he did that because yes please
this uh was completely unexpected we
were looking at the position and you
were showing me that move B5 which would
have kept lenier in the game but take a
look at this take take E4 right and now
he played the move Knight to C3 this was
the move that I wanted to play but Queen
to E1 is just the game is over in fact
after Queen to E1 he tried Rook to d8 of
course you cannot take because I take
take nasty and then you get checkmated
on the first rank so don't touch that
Knight yet but you what you can do is
just simply play excuse me Bishop to B4
Bishop to B4 I'm going to still take
this Knight on C3 and after that I'm
going to follow it up with taking the
Knight on F5 or just simply be two pawns
up
and an open King for you so this is
completely resign which he did lenier
resigned Fabby bounces back important
victory for my pick in the tournament
but I have to say we have a tournament
in this one because everybody's bouncing
back all the players that lost in the
first one are back wow and that
sacrifice was therefore correct by Fabby
Bishop H7 and Knight F7 from a practical
perspective yes from an objective
perspective it lost a little bit of the
advantage
away but still you really had to find
this move
B5 um G takes H6 was not the most
precise King takes H6 was the best but
who takes with the King and leaves it
exposed like that nobody you're going to
take with the pawn like he did and after
E4 again you have to find B5 43 seconds
that's the problem you have to find the
move B5 keeps the game going it's still
not over because take a look at this
variation take take F6 wow don't go to
G8 you get checkmated Queen to G6 Queen
to G7 so you have to go to h8 are you
really going to allow this to arrive on
the board with 40 seconds on the clock
this Pawn up for promotion this queen
coming to G6 and to H6 with upper
Rook black is upper Rook but your king
what's your king been Rooks and this is
not a comfy one uh this was a very very
difficult calculation he did not spot it
with 40 seconds on his clock and Fab
gets his first an important Victory to
bounce back after they after first round
that's standings guys thank you
Christian and indeed do the honors n
what do we have after two rounds we
still have three leaders the same
leaders As Leaders round one Gary
Kasparov Sam Shanklin and Sam seon and
with one point four players following
closely hikaro Nakamura Fabiano caruana
Leon Ron and Wesley s my pick hararo
Nakamura showing his solidity to Safe
quiet easy
draws but fa Leon and Wesley have been
the roller coaster Riders uh wins and
losses and uh with uh the last round of
the day coming up round three uh tell us
about the pairings we have Sam Shanklin
playing Leon Ronan nice the mingas
against Sam savan Right Wesley so
against Fabiano caruana I mean when
those two sit down to play we have to
stop and watch hiar Nakamura against
Jeffrey Jean and Ray Robson playing Gary
kaspar for Gary Gary is saying when I
want to play Ray Robson I want to play
Ray when he's thinking thinking thinking
thinking and more thinking as he really
he lost that game on time as well as
position but really it was uh time Mis
management that's oh yes absolutely no
for sure and almost for Gary as well
right I have to say but Ray what are you
doing spending five minutes on the first
move that's just simply unacceptable and
after that as you can see this positions
and this CH 9 LX positions are so
complex it's so difficult to get out of
the opening but still even if you get
out with the worst position at least you
have some time left on your clock if you
leave yourself 20 seconds to find the
best defense you're not going to find it
then your opponents are going to punish
you and this is exactly what happened
and maybe should have happened in in the
first game as well against hikaro he
just had a much much better position in
that one definitely an intriguing start
to at this one and it just goes to show
that every single player in this
tournament has a chance to potentially
win it all exactly and here to remind
everybody where our picks
were um wow you guys are doing nice
bounce nice bounce back for us a good
round too a good round too uh that start
of the round two where lanir and Ray
both used like three four five minutes
on move one really forcibly reminded me
of David bronin David bronstein at the
time of this Tournament game was one of
the greatest if not the greatest opening
theoretician in the world and he's
playing in Hastings he his first move
his opponent presses the clock and David
thinks for 50 moves 50
minutes on his first move makes a move
and destroys his opponent in a
journalist asked a David after the game
well Mr brunstein what what were you
thinking about for 50 minutes on move
one and David said I was thinking about
what to
play deep thoughts that was what
happened with lanir and Ray they spent
five minutes on move one thinking about
what to play that's why he gets paid the
Big Bus bad
bad and a lot of Chess left in our year
as look at these upcoming events and boy
the US and US Women's National
Championship when I think about Grand
chest tors singfield cups this event the
US Women's and US Open uh championships
are the best they're just great most
exciting tournament for me for sure
exactly and then of course that's
followed immediately with the St Louis
rapid and Blitz and the sville cup to
cap off another grand chest tour tour as
we will be crowning a winner of the
grand chest hor December 1st uh as those
events coming up wow great stuff and NY
I I'm hurt you you said at the opening
ceremony to me I asked you what you're
doing you said you're preparing yourself
for the women's championships and the
first thing you said is please do not
pick me as your je and I said why not
you said you never win I said you're not
counting the moral victories
you were you were afraid I put pressure
on you uh if I chose you I know that
you'll be rooting for me and that's
enough for me that's enough okay I like
that okay I can live with that how about
you uh Christian would you choose Nazi
and
put excess Christian has a lot of
students playing in the ah you're in a
conflict of interest that's right yes
I'm sort of in a conflict of interest
I'm um also doing commentary but also
coaching during the US championships in
general how many hats are you wearing
quite a
few quite and sometimes I'm doing a
podcast on the side as well but I just
was taking a second to uh uh admire that
moment between the players with Wesley
showing his Gambit he was showing this
idea of B5 and Gary comes along and he's
like yeah I think we analyzed something
similar so maybe some influence coming
from Gary with uh that particular
pattern it's all about pattern
recognition and this is what the players
are in fact lacking in chess 9lx because
they spent their whole entire lives
understanding all the patterns to
Perfection from chess from the starting
position of actual classical chess but
whenever you throw this type of unusual
positions they miss certain things and
as you can see Ray missing that move
Bishop to E4 not allowing the Knight to
take on e4 because you get check met on
G7 and he was laughing about it he
understands he's lacking the pattern
recognition that you get as an elite
level player and you're saying what are
you seeing here you're just seeing six
enthusiastic people in love with ch yes
that's exactly what you're seeing right
there have new positions to analyze and
they're sharing with one another I mean
this is really wonderful when I was
growing up as a kid this is this is what
we would do at the club is we'd run to
the club and we were analyzing the
Fisher spasy game
and you know like it would be like 12
hands you know moving pieces around the
board especially when they got adjourn
games then we all wanted to know who was
wi the adj you didn't have engines so we
didn't have engines so much more it was
a mystery we were it was like a a
self-discovery again and just think
about the brain
power in this analysis
session we're about a minute away from
our new reveal for the third and final
round of today again they will be three
round three days of play each day
featuring three rounds and then we we
could have a a playoff tie break right
absolutely because his players
are so close in strength and Gary's
playing so well if he continues wow I
will make day two very exciting for sure
again a reveal uh coming up but uh if
you could uh summarize once again uh
Christian uh decisive
60% for for uh rapid chess and nine LX
yes but let's not forget two of those in
fact finished before the 15th move Mark
so that's quite impressive I have to say
Miniatures all around and of course
we've seen that one aronian versus Ray
Robson That Could Have Ended after 10 15
moves as well Ray was just playing uh
asking leevon to show him the final uh
moves in the position and find the best
moves in the position which he did
leevon definitely and accurately and
comfortably I might add found the best
moves and finished way off so very very
intriguing game so far but it's it's fun
chess n Le I have to say it's a lot of
fun as the chess players gathering
around the arer come on give us our
reveal as here we go what about to see
what happened and and by the way in that
game where Ry did leavon Ron and versus
Ray Ray had that moment where he kind of
burst out into laughter because it was
this crushing move Bishop to E4 and he I
think Ray had seen that and then forgot
about it and then he saw it on the board
and went
oop and here we go drum roll please n we
have knights in the corner both of them
the Bishops look good oh Bishops in
there North noral Queen looks good I
think that this is going to be pretty
normal position both E4 D4 bring out the
bishop like for example Castle either
side easily yeah but for example if I'm
white I'm immediately seeing the scheme
I want to play the move E4 followed by
Bishop C4 followed by Castle later I can
choose to play the move Knight G3 do you
think this is one of those positions
where white has an advantage from the
start no uh this is another one of those
where I think that uh it's really very
feeling more balanced and by the way
we're going to just take a quick break
and we're going to see you on the other
side of the break for round three of
this exciting chess 9 LX don't move
[Music]
away hi Wesley thank you so much for
joining me how do you feel about being
back here in St Louis and competing in
this chess uh well I feel great I'm very
thankful to the St Louis chess club for
hosting this event although of course
you need to have this event because it's
Rex sing Field's birthday and all the
tournaments got moved this year in
grandchester but uh I'm very glad to be
back actually it's only my second time
St Louis this year so uh I'm really
looking forward to it and it's great
that we have American players you know
we have lots of young players and uh you
know to build companionship within the
country so really looking forward to it
and uh hopefully I can do well I'm also
looking forward to the ultimate moves
and also the uh analysis sessions before
the games uh what is your favorite um
way of playing chess do you prefer
classical chess rapid blades which one
would you say it's is your favorite oh
well I'm trying to improve my classical
chess I've been trying the entire year
with no success but uh chess has really
changed a lot compared to when I first
started 10 years ago so there's a lot
more online there's a lot more rapid and
Blitz uh I think it
started first because of of course the
world rapid and Blitz and then it
started because of the ranchester rapid
in Blitz tournaments in
2015 and
um I'm still trying to focus on
classical because in my opinion Blitz is
not really chess it's more about
flagging your flagging the hell out out
of your
opponent but uh uh in terms of money and
sponsorship I think it's more gearing
towards faster time controls interesting
so classical chess I I always thought
maybe you like rapid a little bit more
but it's seem it seems have have better
so so classical chest is far harder M
and it takes a lot longer takes twice
the amount uh with ravum blitz you can
be pretty chill pretty relaxed you don't
really have to do specific
preparation but
uh yeah I mean chess is not supposed to
be easy so of course and this time
around you are here for chess 9lx Fisher
random how do you feel about this
variant is it your favorite variant and
what did you do particularly to prepare
for this tournament well this variant
for sure is very
interesting uh it removes all
preparations there there are millions
and millions of chess games played
already so there's very there's not as
much creativity as there used to be and
also with the powerful computers you
know you have unfortunately you have to
use it but t960 is very interesting
because because there's no way to
prepare so you basically start playing
by yourself on on move two maybe not
move one because everyone analyzes but
I'm on move three and uh it's very
interesting my results on chess 960 have
been very mixed uh it's been very up and
down I had good tournaments and and bad
remember there was an online back in
2002 where I did decently you became a
Fisher r a moral Champion one year a few
years back didn't you 2019 19 yeah yeah
it was back when it was a match format
now hearo has it so it's going to be
very interesting so I don't know
remember 2019 I was just in preparation
for tournament I was studying my
opponent's games and studying their
Styles and it worked very well um but my
Souls have been up and down uh and uh
the time control also plays a lot of
factor because uh by in 2019 the time
control was longer here it's so you have
20 20 minutes with I believe 10 seconds
increment or 20 plus 10 yeah yeah so how
do you feel about that time control and
how do you feel about the fact that you
only have 15 minutes before knowing I
mean you get 15 minutes to get prepared
for your next round yeah it's
interesting I mean I like
the camarad in companionship of
analyzing with other players but maybe
to be frank it's not really that useful
because you have very little time and
maybe sometimes just better to have a
clear head and focus on the game uh
because I remember that what F was doing
the entire last year when when he won
the event
so that's interesting and is there a
particular um exercise that you found
effective to improve your visualization
skills in and maybe 60 as well well I'm
probably not the best person to ask that
based on my results but uh I do some
warm up you know like uh analyzing
difficult
positions uh just just before uh again
with very limited time control it you
have to pay huge amount of attention to
the clock but uh if if you have more
time perhaps analyzing your opponents
and figuring them out is also good way I
see final question Wesley uh how do you
feel who's the player that you're
looking the most forward to to playing
against in this tournament uh in this in
this field Gary everyone says Gary so
yeah you played against him before right
yeah you should check out YouTube in
2016 2016 my Blitz game against Gary but
uh uh Gary has always been uh uh I've
always been a big fan of Gary because I
remember back in
2000 I think year 2000 I was playing
some kidy tourament in the Philippines
and the prices were Gary casparo books
and also his matches with kaspar Robin
with an carob so I never imagin that I
would meet Gary in person so I always a
big admiration for him and I still
amazing after
18 years out of retirement that he can
still play very decent uh CH and he's
ready he's ready for
it he's not going to lose eight games in
a row I think he's ready for it yeah but
yeah but irregardless you know he's he's
a living legend and
uh
uh uh yeah when in in his prime he was
really amazing
like it'd be interesting to see uh how
he would do against uh Magnus if if they
were in the same
era but I also look forward of course to
playing against uh Fabiano and hikaro
who've been doing very well recently so
big congratulations to to him for doing
well the World Cup thank you very much
Wesley and I wish you good luck looking
forward to seeing you play at this
tournament yeah I'm very excited also
want to wish Rex singfield a very happy
birthday looking forward to playing him
later
[Music]
the St Louis chess club will be hosting
its 13th annual charity golf tournament
on October 2nd at Glen eeko Country Club
this charity golf tournament supports
the club Scholastic chess initiative in
providing chess to over 100 schools in
the St Louis area to sponsor this event
or to enter your team please go to St
Louis chess club.org and click on the
events tab that's the St Louis chess
club 13th annual charity golf tournament
on October 2nd at gleno Country
Club the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
Le ures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
[Music]
CH welcome back everyone we had two
rounds so far yes we did and they've
been ex exciting rounds at that the
standings Nasi let's take a look we have
three leaders Gary Kasparov Sam shanan
and Sam savan with one and a half points
and they all got here by the same uh way
they won their first round and Drew
second round games please there are four
players following closely with 50%
Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano kirana leevon
aronian and Wesley s Hikaru got there by
two draws but the other three players
threw uh roller coaster up and down
crazy games Wesley just won his game in
13 moves in the last round indeed and uh
tell us about round three pairings
coming up we have Sam Shanklin playing
Leon aronian Dominguez against Sam saan
nice weso against Fano Carana hikaro
against Jeffrey and Ray Robson against
Gary Kasparov Sam Shanklin leavon Ron
and in terms of points that's a marquee
matchup but Gary gasparo doing so very
well uh nice for us to keep an eye on
him and Ray needs to do something about
his time management we'll see if those
two players both Ray and Gary not great
with her time as we see the players kind
of birds of a feather flocking together
as uh uh three tables Changing Partners
each round exactly I change well I see
Gary and hikaro are back together right
they were together in the first round uh
then they had to play against each other
so they separated and now they're back
and Wesley kind of joining in yes on the
side there side I guess he enjoyed his
analysis with Gary he came up with that
B5 pretty idea of B5 right uh by the way
we do see the signature of the play
players it says official
chess number five what is this CH chess
set number five so it is the
authentication of the chess sets Perhaps
it is yeah yeah what I was saying so
when the player pardon me when the
public is invited to bid on the sets to
own a piece of history and they say and
this chess set was used in the chess 9lx
round
three there's Gary Kasparov signature to
say yeah I uh the provance is approved I
like this I like this idea yeah that's
great I tell you uh I went to the Buenos
Iris chess club in woar Argentina and I
sat down at the same chess set and table
that was used by Capa Blanca and alakin
in their world championship match and I
said wow you know if I were to buy this
table you know how what would it cost me
they said well the Soviets offered is a
million dollars and we
refused I said okay well that's outside
of my
budget just
asking is that Christian one of those
those moments if you got to ask you
can't afford it kind of situations kind
of yes kind of or if you cannot buy it I
think 10 or 20 times what's what's the
saying if you cannot buy it over 10
times then you shouldn't buy it you
shouldn't buy it uh again uh two a Time
trouble time troubled players facing off
but when you think about what Gary has
done I'm going to I'm I'm I'm not going
to go too far out on limb but this by
far has been his best art in any of the
editions not even comparable to any
other one exactly exactly and uh there
you know Gary getting the bit between
his teeth you know you don't want to
encourage him too much he might he might
be a force to be reckoned with can he
keep it up for days in a row who is
going to get in time trouble first who
is going to or Gary under one minute I'm
gonna say Gary since his was black I
will say Ray I'm gonna go with Ray with
the tiebreaker I you you guys have made
two excellent
picks I'm gonna go with Ry as well and
something tells me that Ry is still
smarting whereas Gary is feeling better
feeling better about himself about his
decisions and hearu didn't punish him
for taking so long on the clock whereas
Ray did get punished uh the the random
position is random position 593 we we
we're thinking that actually this isn't
that a difficult position to get started
with because the pieces the Bishops on
are on the original squares and the
Knights are so easy to develop once you
play Move C2 C4 the Knight on A1 for
example will jump to B3 or C2 whereas
the Knight on H1 is definitely
definitely jumping to G3 but um it's
unlucky for Gary he can't really get
King Indian cuz knight from h8 cannot
get to F6 exactly he's not getting his
beloved G6 Bishop G7 that Knight on h8
kind of and D2 D4
Gary Gary is probably thinking about uh
some kind of a queen Indian setup and
I'm thinking he's ready to play the move
B5 wow ready to play B5 followed by E6
fean sheding his Bishop to B7 dropping
his Knight to B6 so I would not be
surprised by the move B5 what in regular
chess we might call the Polish opening
you will be surprised by his move he
played Knight
G6 that is a very surprising move for me
I find that very surprising because
that's the kind of move that if for
example you could just have castled you
could say to yourself I'll always play
Knight G6 something else needs to be
done for c5d E5 E6 something else but so
Knight G6 quite the surp and again the
surprise continues Knight G3 as well
again I would have said that is a Tempo
I can waste or use later it's more
important that I play C4 or E4 than
Knight G3 well Gary played D5 so I don't
think we're goingon to see
E4 nope no e4s okay um
it's time right C2 C4 let's get that guy
going uh and if I take You'll Play E4
yes so let's just put that on the board
just it is a a kind of a pawn sacrifice
you're welcome to try to keep it after a
move like B3 I feel these positions
offer good um compensation but I take a
quick look and in four out of five games
we have both Knights already on G3 and
G6 no kidding I would have gotten that
so wrong you're right I'm looking at
they very uncomfortable with the knights
in the cor I'm looking at the game
between Hikaru and and Jeffrey and the
players really went something really
went wrong here C4 C4 by the way does
threatening is pardon me does threaten
Queen takes H7 maybe that's a pawn
sacrifice you're willing to make by the
way H2
H4
C5 isn't that inviting H5 and queen H7
what's going on maybe Knight E5 and take
on C4 perhaps no Queen H and the which
one H5 there's Queen H2 thre right yeah
uh Queen H2 threat
and uh this is this is different
Christian uh jump in on this one uh whoa
Knight takes H4 things are happening
yeah we most likely going to see uh a
trade of these H pawns I can take
directly but perhaps I want to play Rook
to H1 first you cannot touch that pawn
on G2 right Rook H1 Knight takes G2 King
to F1 and the Knight is uh trapped and
the problem is you cannot attack my
knight on G3 with a move of H4 because
there's a pin along the H5 exact so I
like this idea of Rook to H1 forcing the
Knight to get back to G6
potentially and this is the pin you were
just discussing that it just feels like
white got more moves in somehow like it
got E3 you got Bishop E2 you developed a
little bit right right E3 Bishop E2 how
did you smuggle those Tempe I know I
know it's it's magic wait a minute that
that that's not the way it's supposed to
work uh let's just jump around a little
bit uh Ray Robson and Gary are slow
playing it we're we're keeping a careful
eye on the clock to determine
who spends the time more
unwisely that didn't come out the way I
meant it um Fabby versus Wesley so check
this out we were saying Gary couldn't
play the Kings Indian because the Knight
on
h8 uh is so bad well Fabby says that's
not true I can play a kind of a
fianchetto because I can play F5 and
Knight F7 as well uh keep that in mind
as uh this is a key matchup between
Wesley and Fabby I'm really not loving
White's development here with Rook on D4
so definitely not hling long um we can
fiano our white squared Bishop so we
have to play E3 at some point right
Bishop D3 will be scary to play cuz
Rooks on D4 Rooks on D4 can I just throw
one at you though uh the move Rook H4 as
weird as it is and the and the opening
once again let me emphasize the Rooks
are so clumsy I'm probably going to lose
my Rook doing what I just did by the way
but you understand what I'm doing I if
you
play I'm glad we're on the same page
Rook
H4 provoking H5 what do you think of
them apples uh Christian is that
ridiculous sure feels like I'm cruising
for a bruising here personally yes I
think it's kind of ridiculous but but
having said that why not why not why not
why not well if you do play H5 which you
may not want to do E4 this looks like
another miniature about to happen for
somebody we just just not 100% Who okay
what if I give you that H7 Pawn somehow
and try to play for the initiative you a
nice love
letter uh what are you going to do what
if I go the bo Queen E5 first or Knight
F7 I'll let you uh get the Rook to H7
Wesley played Rook H4 okay I tell you I
mean he sensed opportunity okay and now
let's go Queen E5 let's try to activate
my queen somehow but it's kind of funny
as as as awkwardly placed as The Rook on
H7 is it's not easy to attack like which
piece are you go like you're going to go
Knight G5 I might be tempted to play F4
I'm thinking about going and trying to
uh tackle that Knight on G3 the position
of that Knight on G3 Knight G5 Bishop G5
Bishop G5 yeah I I'm thinking I want to
play E4 I'm thinking I want to play F4
yeah yeah it's he did play E5 so he
sacrificing he's sacrificing the pawn
but he's doing it on his terms it feels
like the right thing to do it feels like
you have to do that don't go H5 don't
weaken the position even more just try
to play For Speed speed in the position
perhaps this is what Fabiano is going
for okay uh uh pursue the the I think he
wants to go E4 E4 I think he wants to
close up the Queen close up somewhat the
Knight on G3 as well perhaps this is his
idea okay I now that you mentioned my
queen uh there is Knight takes E4 right
right you can yeah you can surely try to
take that I mean what we talk about
Miniatures I me y mate that's a mate
that's a that's actually a pretty funny
mate I that's a
mate a rook on H7 and it's made that's
that's crazy by the way I've told my my
my pick Hikaru just made a big time BL
oh my goodness see oh my good what did
he do he took on H5 I can take on H5 and
queen H2 oh
oh those those dirty double attacks but
there is a trap of your queen
Knight G3 Queen G1 king2 and then Rook
yes nzi exactly the queen it's funny you
do get two Rooks for the queen though
right I mean let's be let's be fair okay
this is not easy I've been looking
through the variations this is
definitely not easy wa he included D5
somewhere yes so take a look at this
okay I take I take D5 first we will
understand in just a second why this is
L not is it to my eyes not even humanly
possible take Queen to H2 because you're
not looking in this direction you see
Queen H2 you see Knight G3 and you
understand that you cannot take on G1
because your queen gets trapped right so
that's a problem but take a look at this
you have this extra move
F5 you cannot because you included D5
exactly just because you included
there's no way no no no no no no you
cannot find this over the board I mean
sure with 20 minutes to think yes maybe
you can find that but not with that and
of course the idea is that you cannot go
to C2 because you're Pawn on G2 is Hing
right you need your queen on e4 exactly
or F3 and if you go to F3 I have Knight
to H4 and the position still continues
you give me a check I go G6 everything
has to be calculated because if you miss
one move then the position completely
changes he did he missed it he missed
well but to be fair who can see F5 D5 no
you got to include D5 and then you got
to include F5 not humanly possible not
humanly so the current position with
Rook on H6 however once again it does
feel like white is cheated he's got his
Bishop on F1 to H5 he's got his Queen on
B1 to E4 in the meanwhile White made too
many moves too many moves and black got
his Rook to H6 as some recompense that's
not fair does feel like with D4 and or
Knight B3 White's development Advantage
will be increased you feel comfortable
to Castle here short with the open H
file or you wouldn't risk it no I
wouldn't the funny part is if I had my
Bishop on B2 I'd be castling long
yeah maybe why you should do that B3 B3
I was thinking more directly D4 and you
know uh Knight with with or without
Knight B3 three cuz that does come with
a Tempo against the C5 Pawn I think
Hikaru is looking good in this one let
me just jump in on the ray uh Ray Ray
versus Gary Kasparov game because I'm
more than curious about the
time and they've only made five moves
yes but I can't see I can't see their
clock clock surprisingly uh raise ahead
I was right I was
right no I was
right
who was right I was saying that Ray
would use more clock let's wait and see
let's wait and see let's wait and see
raise on 16 13 to 16 so Gary has used
more clock and I was wrong so far now I
understand why you didn't want me to
choose you for the
US and moves in does look a little he's
got a little look of concern there is
the move Bishop G5 that's an an
antagonizing move the queen on
B1 I mean the desirable move is F7 F6
boot that Bishop out grab that pawn you
know with evil intent but F6 just loses
the Knight with check and the move
Bishop G5 is
actually more than annoying I think Gary
is Gary is calculating let's see what I
mean he's got that that
ferocious look about him I Gary is
calculating Knight
A7 to C7 it would be very intimidating
to sit in front of him when he's in that
position don't you tell me about it I
mean I had Wars
with where he is smashing the clock with
you know a closed fist I mean it's great
stuff uh KN C7 as expected on the board
Gary's essaying a PE peace sacrifice a
pawn sacrifice Knight takes H5 Knight E6
is on his agenda uh he's saying I'm
prepared to sacrifice a pawn for the two
Bishops later I'll play Rook h8 and uh
you'll have invested a lot of time for a
double Pawn Christian what's caught your
eye leavon in a bit of a pickle uh right
now in his game against Sam shanglin
because take a look at this and we see
the influence of their team himself uh
alongside Fabiano and lenier because
Fabiano we remember he played the move
G6 followed by F5 tried to get this
Dutch type of structure get the Knight
to F7 develop like that and this is what
aronian is doing as well he played the
move G6 to defend the pawn you have to
defend the pawn on H7 right either
Knight G6 either G6 and he decides to go
influenced perhaps by their analyses
with a move G6 E4 but I don't like this
I don't like this Knight on h8 and you
have to spend so many resources to get
it into the game and unfortunately once
again we once again see the space
Advantage is giving in my estimation and
stock fish's estimation as well white a
pretty significant Advantage F6 F4 and
we get this position on the board and
right now I have to say it's starting to
look like a very normal position the
problem is what is this queen on ba8
doing hitting uh this uh Pawn wall as
well as the bishop Pawn G7 hitting that
pawn wall I have to give it to Sam
Shanklin right now he has the better
position he has the easier moves I'm
going to reroute the knight from B3 to D
E4 F3 somewhere around the center and
you're going to have some difficult
times finding a plan right now it's all
about finding an indication right there
with the retreat Knight G4 Knight G4
Bishop D2 Knight H6 you know something
Advanced carolon bad for black exactly
exactly yeah it feels like uh uh poorly
Ed uh play Knight H6 and Sam Shanklin
enjoying the position let me just go
around the horn a little bit laner
versus um Sam Sean we're seeing a lot of
games that are featuring this H5 H4
business with both black winning the H
Pawn as well as white winning the H Pawn
uh as well this one is a strange one I'm
just Rook H1
E4 and what is going on here it seems
wrong to have the bishop on H4 but I
don't know how to punish it at the
moment I let me just throw out a move
here I'm not particularly proud of my
move E5 I'll take on G3 yep as as
expected you should my intention maybe
D6 yep D6 Bishop to D3 and here's what
my real intention was even though I
realize it's not that great if you do
play back to E7 KN to E7 I was thinking
I'm going to get something with Bishop
f4 on on the board how I'm going to do
that I'm not sure the queen looks a
little bit trapped there but the
immediate Bishop F4 might
induce uh Knight D5 takes F4 uh lanir is
going to have to prove himself here on
this one jumping into Wesley versus
Fabby this was the one where Wesley went
Pawn hunting with Rook H4 take the
pawn wow having said a you're supposed
to to say B Knight C2 by Wesley
remarkable decision not to play Rook
takes H7 Fabby said haha too late you
should have taken the pawn bishop G5
whoa so if you take Bishop d8 Quinn
takes back and your Rook is actually
trapped yeah that is one of the most
clumsy Rooks I've ever seen E4 on the
board this game blowed up and uh okay
Christian I'm not sure
blew up on Fabby played really well he
did he he did this E5 move was key and
let's understand why it was key you
cannot well you can but it's going to
lead to a very dangerous position not
after E4 what we were discussing but
just a simple Bishop to B4 check B4
check there's no Knight on B1 to go to
C3 right right so you go Bishop D2 now I
force your king to get in the center
where my rookies by by the way the
rookies on d8 I'm going to go D5 at some
point open up that uh line that and
you're in trouble can Castle yep I
understand now for black you have to go
back with the Rook you're in trouble so
Knight C2 was designed to stop the
bishop coming to B4 check and and the
idea is that if you do take on H first
of all if you go H5 first as black
instead of this move
E5 there's a nice strategical touch to
the position I go
E4 and now you have to be ready to meet
that with F4 that's why he played
E5 right and if you don't have E5 to
play the move F4 then you're in some
sort of a trouble because the light
squares are getting very soft around the
king nice so now we're kind of but in
this exact moment we've seen the move
Bishop G5 uh hitting the trapped Rook on
d8 and after Queen C7 E4 four white
isn't white a favorite to win material
uh Christian well the thing is if you
take on d8 I take with a queen and where
is your R why play Rook
H3 hi hide like trembling in the corner
absolute fear then I go Knight F7 Knight
G5 I will get to that rook and if you
have to go by the way Rook H3 and then
Knight H1 to open up the third rank for
the Rook to escape I I think I have
enough compensation agree but after E4
it's uh it's fobby to play and the
clocks even though the players haven't
used haven't played many moves 12
minutes for fabbi 10 minutes for Wesley
wow I mean we were jokingly pointing out
that Ray and and Gary were the two uh
offenders if you will worst offenders
for for for time but these two they
might win is so unusual that you really
have to think and from the looks of it
Wesley doesn't look too happy with his
position yeah but maybe not so concerned
either I mean he kind of thought we can
play Knight F7 right away okay let's
let's uh let's break it down Knight F7
provoking Bishop d8 well now that you've
provoked me I guess I have to take take
take uh three G5 Knight G5 but now I'm
going to be very gracious not always but
in this moment I'm going to be gracious
I'm going to return the
exchange uh have to take it yet well
well actually maybe I don't maybe you do
I'm not sure uh E4 takes F5 if you do
take I'm thinking and if you do take
there is some action Visa the two
players have made this moves by the way
we have them on the board okay currently
and we do expect Wesley to now Play3 on
my move right I think yes uh
sacrificing no nobody believes you as
uh bent Larson famously told
me it's still very
hurtful I mean I had made the most
brilliant Cod argument of all time too I
mean it only took him like a few seconds
after I paused for breath and he told me
nobody believes you Rook H3 that hurts
that hurts uh there is some also a
different way of spearing The Rook right
you you could try for F4 and D5 business
I'm not saying you should uh oh excuse
me uh it is a it it it is not fam we are
not a familiar ground let's just put it
that way there's no pattern recognition
in this position and the other thing
that could blow up Queen A5 check sorry
Christian but that's a good point with
the pattern recognition because after
Knight G5 everything connects very well
for black you go Knight G5 I take on F5
I take on H3 and after you take back on
H3 I take on F5 you cannot take back on
F5 because the G file has opened and the
Rooks are on the same there's some
patterns that don't exist in classical
chess that you see in this type of CH
continue the POS continue the game for
one mo more move Christian I'm not going
to go H4 after Bishop
E2 uh you're not happy by Bishop H5 CH
yes but I think I can go Queen H4
doesn't that allow me to sacrifice my
queen and once again we see the P up on
the first
rank Queen H4 what is that Queen on B1
do that's a darn good well now that you
mention it let's bring that now I go F4
and my king runs away to d8 how do you
defend paa paa paa because you're you in
the immortal words of somebody you can
run but you can't hide Joe Lewis I think
Queen D5 Bishop H5 Queen A5 check ooh
you have ideas I'll give you that okay
let's put him on the board Queen a what
if I take on G3 is that oh take G three
is possible let me show what yaser might
have missed might have missed takes
takes uh so yeah there is that Bishop H5
check
first queen comes to D5 same right same
ideas right I think I can do that and
you I I have Queen G5 Queen G5 always to
defend the Rook always defends The Rook
wow okay I for sure the players Wesley
and Fabby two great calculating players
they must be looking and that's probably
why they've consumed so much time
there's no again there's no patterns to
latch on to right as as a player that is
so used to calculate certain patterns
but not these ones you have to recognize
Fabby is under eight minutes I mean and
he doesn't look like he's ready to move
maybe he's not going to go5 not as bad
as Gary's clock down under six minutes
boy did you get it right
okay so when we left it we left it after
the move Knight C7 E3 by Ray Knight E6
Ray said you know what you're right Gary
I don't need that uh H Pawn and let me
just play without capturing the H Pawn
we have H4 on the on the position Knight
E2 what is the clocks uh 11 and a half
against 5 and a half okay but uh's doing
great on the clock position
but yeah why isn't well excuse me but
I'm kind
ofing kind of liking black yeah why not
but we do have very close position and
you have bishop and the Knight I have
two knights okay but what I'm thinking
is Black's King is actually running the
safety probably white will do the same
castle long as well yeah so first of all
where were we moving the the queen I see
we're going to go D3 David 3 everybody
castle castle castle
castle
and well I want to win this Pawn I think
longterm H4 Pawn is weaker than G5 that
was my question I want to win the pawn
on E on G5 but I don't want you to play
F4 so to in order to stop you from
playing F4 and defending the pawn I'm
going to have to play the move E5 so let
me start with E5 idea E4 Bishop E7 he
went Queen G4 by the way he went Queen
G4 here what if I play Queen F5 you go
into the end game
yep will go trading and here's the
question that you asked uh the players
are about to prove which Pawn is weaker
the pawn on G5 or the pawn on H4 none of
this happened why because after the move
Queen pardon me after the move E6 we
have Queen G4 and immediately E5 so
similar ideas by Gary maybe Queen
E6 and E4 is on his agenda from White's
perspective I still think you're right I
think he's going to Castle Queen side
but this Knight needs to jump right into
the game either Knight B3 probably yeah
Knight
B3 uh clock times once again 10 to 5
yeah okay and what's caught your eye um
Christian lener versus Sam Sean that's
an intriguing position and I have to
give it to lenier right now it seems
like he just just simply have uh has the
best the better pieces in the position
the more active pieces in the position
that Knight ready to jump to C5 the
Knight on eight you seem with the black
pieces that you're a bit behind right
now and I have to say that Knight on F4
doesn't have a strong Outpost directly
hit by the bishop on uh C1 and that
Queen on B8 is tied to the defense of it
so I'm looking at the position I see a
lot of plans for White Knight to C5
maybe D5 at the right moment try to open
up your king I have a lot of ideas you
don't and that's a problem and
especially that Knight on F4 seems a bit
feeble right now in the position lener
for choice you you described it
perfectly the way I think about uh chess
and my pieces as well I mean I'm looking
at the bishop on C1 I'm proud I'm
looking at the bishop on F3 I'm proud
I'm looking at this Knight coming to C5
you guys are all working well done well
well done looking at the Knight on A8
I'm going dude you haven't earned your
oats I mean what are you doing you're
not justifying Your Existence it's just
about that Knight on F4 right cuz you
would love to control that C5 square
with D6 but you cannot do that you that
would undermine your support you would
love to go back with a knight to G6 but
you cannot do that cuz I'll hit it with
H5 exactly it's not looking good we have
crazy updates in Wesley against Faby
game let's go let's do it N5 did not
happen whoa I couldn't guess I think no
that I'm in the wrong game I Wesley whoa
what the it blowed up move D5 is okay we
left it after Rook H3 and suddenly
H4 so there's no Knight G5 okay no
Knight G5 Knight
E2 he took a pawn so he's got Pawn for
exchange and now D5 I mentioned what if
I take on D5 I'll be happy to give up
that Rook for the white square with the
KN or the pawn actually either looks
good but maybe with the pawn okay let
start let's do that I can have Bishop B5
check yes so in case I we gain The
Exchange we have this on the board right
now we do have it on the
board oh Knight G5 G the idea well let
me
return the favor sh B5 check exactly
that looks like King
F7 your guess as good as mine yeah I
like White's position here you only have
one uh lousy check and sorry I have a
question can White Castle here legally
they can okay Rook hasn't been moved
well actually it's funny Let me let me
prove it by doing it right uh there was
this great uh commentary where you know
uh uh Peter was playing against Lawrence
Trent
and he was explaining the software and
how wonderful it was and he suddenly it
didn't allow him to play off I remember
that was pretty funny uh Bishop B5 check
King F7 even I can just you know again
there's only one threat in the position
Bishop eat uh Bishop Knight F3 check so
I can avoid that if I can still Castle
short then maybe even instead of Bishop
B5 check I could play Bishop G2 and then
just Castle short
yes but in that case you're that's okay
CU look at black spawns exactly they're
so bad they are they are so bad and if
you do ever manage to Wrangle a
situation where you have a minor piece
lording over E4 Square it's going to be
a very good position for w white can
play Knight E3 take on e4 even bring the
queen into the game agreed agreed all
around um what do you think about uh uh
Fab's treatment in this game
uh where he played this F E4 and D5 not
great not great he missed that
opportunity with Knight G5 that was the
key moment but once again you have to
calculate everything and it's not easy
with these shorttime controls but do you
remember when I told you that I love Sam
shanklin's position and that leevon is
in big trouble well things have
completely changed in this one and in
fact it is leevon who now has a winning
position completely winning yes Rook to
D1 Queen to A6 look at all the pieces he
managed to find the right squares for
them this night even the Knight on H6 is
ready to jump to F5 put it on the
Outpost on F5 blockate the structure of
white F5 he decides to sacrifice the
pawn and now we have this position if
you do continue to take I will just
simply take take you lose the pawn on E5
I defend the Knight on E6 I'm a pawn up
this Knight on B3 is completely out of
play I'm ready to take on A2 ready to
take over the game in this one not
looking good for white right so what he
played after G takes F5 Bishop to C3
this is what we have on the board Rook
takes D1 but isn't this just a pawn up
for very nice hands King sa all of my
pieces are on the right squares my queen
is ready to go to C4 and enter the
Freight in the in the position maybe
even get centralized via C4 E4 it's
looking good for black I have see I'm
looking at the position leevon in Pole
Position potentially score back-to-back
victories wow very nice indeed and I
love the move Queen C4 turn around yeah
and uh I was going to say I love this
idea of centralizing the queen putting
the queen on e4 Queen C4 got my vote but
Queen B7 was chosen by leavon same idea
similar ideas of just centralizing the
queen extra Pawn looking good let me
just the crazy position is in hikaro
game where they still haven't developed
really uh they only played 11 moves and
both players their clock times are down
to four and five sorry I and somehow
there is a black Pawn on D3 chicar
having four minutes after 11 moves is
unbelievable yeah that feels
unprecedented and D5 on the board uh
what is going on here you liking
Jeffrey's position now are you uh I'm
still I'm trying to get the Zen of it so
if I take Queen takes I guess it's
Knight B6
I want play Knight C6 so
badly no can do uh Queen takes D3 uh he
car took on D5 oh pardon me and we have
Rook takes D5 on the board okay we do
have takes Rook takes D5 and Rook D3 and
Rook D3 so now probably Knight B6 makes
a lot of sense to me also black cannot
Castle anymore but neither can white so
well
yeah why can't
we uh yeah okay
um but some Bishop G6 Rook G6 Rook h8 or
is just looks good but doesn't actually
do anything Bishop G6 Rook G6 invade
Rook h8 look scary but maybe Queen D6 I
don't know yeah might be just Queen D6
just defending f8 and hard put pressure3
there's no Bishop
A3 right I mean you you definitely need
your knight on C2 in order to play
Bishop A3 and and justify this uh this
Invasion okay well keep an eye on that
one and Christian what do you got for us
well I'm wondering who's paying for a
dinner tonight and I think it's nazy
because uh she was the one that said Ray
is going to be ahead on time yes was
ahead on time for a little while but
right now he's down to his last three
minutes against 5 minutes for Gary Gary
is speeding up and he's actually in a
better position right now and let's take
a look at what's happening look at him
confident he looks you can see the body
language yeah right now Ray is a bit
worried about the position what have I
done wrong why did I let him off the
hook but there was no hook in the
position Gary played a really good game
once again he's been playing really good
chess n up to this point by the way
Queen takes D7 check King takes D7
that's a that's a move right out of my
own Playbook I loved the uh such
recaptures with the King uh oh and
Castle cast but he did that in a weird
way right he captured his King with the
Rook I think that's how you're supposed
to no no no no you're you're supposed to
touch the king first first okay yeah he
captured the king with his rook and
somehow they both landed on the proper
squares but it through the magic of
Television we get a replay now you're
supposed to grab your king first first
captures The Rook yeah he can do that
yeah as long as he didn't touch the Rook
first if he touches the Rook first then
it's then he has to move the Rook right
because the idea is castles is a move
with the King and therefore you're
required to move your king
first let's jump back to that crazy game
of Hikaru and uh um Jeffrey Jeffrey for
just a moment because we we got an
update that hikaro blundered something
he just played the move on H1 to D1 what
has he BL what did he blunder that you
have been so sharp today and now you're
asking me is there a queen is there a
queen like f no that's ridiculous I
can't play F5 because my
queen my queen is running out of moves
immediate I mean it's kind of funny that
que
F3 Queen E2 yeah I'm just I'm being
bounced around no I don't see it myself
uh what do we have on the board so play
bishop7 he did Play Bishop B7 I believe
so or perhaps he didn't no he didn't not
yet but Rook on H1 to D1 I was still I
was still uh looking at those Rook h8
ideas uh back to Wesley and Fabby for
just a moment because it's been a
massive reduction for just a second
because Bishop to E7 is indeed the right
move and it gives black a pretty
significant advantage seriously he
what's the idea of Bishop B7 so what are
you going to do after well the idea was
I was threatening to play Rook D5 and
Rook D5 corre right so Bishop E7 blocks
the idea but the
desirable Bishop moves I could get my
queen trapped so the problem is I don't
have a
good scheme follow and not only that but
the bishop Pawn E7 is ready to jump to
H4 that's going to create another very
unpleasant pin
right and um to be honest I don't see
how you deal with that because you can
take on D5 and this is perhaps the
important step in Black setup you have
to take with the pawn with the pawn yes
with the pawn with the
pawn by the way Hikaru uh for someone
who has the reputation of a speed demon
a very deserved reputation as of an
outstanding Blitz player he's really
used a outstanding bullet player truly
but is Jeffrey
actually oh boy one minute one minute to
three and hi CaRu he's not jiving with
the position he's he's really really
does like it problem he doesn't like it
if I take Bishop G6 after Rook G6 Bishop
H4 is just winning problem Eternal p and
he's done it Rook takes D5 Knight takes
D5 that's the point E4 takes D5 was not
an obvious E6 takes D5 pardon taking
with the pawn was not obvious to me no I
thought I wanted to take with the Knight
so I could play Bishop to D7 to C6 sorry
please nazy now maybe white can take on
G6 and go Rook
H1 but then why did I put Rook on D1 it
was a
mistake just admit that I made a bad
move and just take it but after Bishop C
Bishop G6 Pardon Me Oh Bishop F3 okay
okay that's far more human but it does
allow Bishop H4 also Knight H4 isting oh
sorry Rook takes D5 is on my agenda
right so Knight H4 looks maybe tempting
okay
fair by the way five ideas you know it's
kind of funny but if it was my move in
this position as white I'd be
considering Knight F5 right so it's
funny that you should play Knight H4
which stops me from playing Knight I
didn't realize that's what I was doing I
know exactly exactly isn't it annoying
and now it's official Nazi is paying for
dinner tonight because
uh go the first under one minute yep oh
oh oh well let's go to that game I think
Ray will be paying for dinner
tonight as G by the way it's not just
about the clock but it's about the
position I like Gary's position a lot
Knight to D2 because I'm seeing the
bishop coming to an anchor Square Bishop
G3 I'm seeing this Knight coming to D6
where it's tickling the F Pawn black has
the open f file so Rook D3 pardon me
Rook E3 is an invasive move um traffic
is going well
F6 that stops 95 wins this he's going to
finish day one very strong like
like very very strong uh I would say
that clear first by the way e
F6 and by the way that extra little
twist did you notice that extra little
twist trust me I was on the receiving
side of those twists you know that twist
very well yes I mean 96 94 this is ugly
this very very impressive play I think
black is objectively winning and so far
ahead on the clock 10 seconds
for got to make a move Ray he's up
against the 60y old former world
champion but the former world champion
is not playing like a 60y old yeah is he
going to age1 no he's going to go to G4
but then I don't know what he's doing on
G4 when you go to G4 I can play Rook E4
exactly there's no threat 96 okay 94 yes
yeah I mean this is a siren song uh
calling gift me the pawn Knight G4 as
expected but I don't like what Ray is
doing he's inviting Rook E4 as you said
Knight F2 and Rook E2 so free
Tempo oh I live for those moments maybe
even Rook F4 to take the pawn on F5 now
you're thinking the training is working
it's finally
working good for you rookie four oh this
is ugly totally Knight
F2 oh
depending on your perspective this is
actually beautiful I mean the way Gary
has conducted this endgame is going
about making doing his business no
question Rook F4 I love that move but
equally I must say I'm attracted to
rookie too rookie 2 is just rookie 2 and
rookie four both look so temp so good
what do you do uh nassi when you have
two really compelling moves and you've
got to make a practical decision like
this go with the one that's easier that
gives my opponent less counterplay which
would be rookie two in this case which
he played well last counter play now now
that you said that Rook F4 would have
prevented Knight G4 right he played
Knight E4 and he played Knight E oh
that's nasty I mean white cannot move
yeah you defend the pawn on F6 Rook B1
that's a sad move to make what did he do
Rook B1
is running out of moves it feels like
strangulation uh Gary's looking
for blow yes yes feeling it right now he
he's considered taking on G5 but he
didn't want to allow Knight E5 with a
check great keep making moves with one
second on the clock what move did he
make with one second to D1 you have one
half threat in what's the half threat I
don't even see King f one thank you that
is a half threat so Gary said excuse me
that's a pawn I'll take the pawn the
half threat I can deal with by moving my
Rook luckily I still have one square on
C but one square is enough D3 with one
second no Knight E3 by the way Rook F2
uh Rook to D3 can I go Rook f8 Rook f8
looks very good yeah okay what's what's
we SP one minute for Gary there's no the
10 seconds and rook f8 and again that
extra little
twist beautiful game play it is it is it
is what a what a game trust me when Gary
was in formed H3
oh oh wow he's feeling it right now oh
trust me when Gary is in form he is a
force okay he's G4 G4 trust me guys
G4
take out the gold coins let's start
throwing them at the board yes he
deserves G4 or Bishop F4 or Rook h8 I
think they're all winning moves all good
but something about G4 just find the H
Rook h8 he's taking it slow he's
enjoying the moment right now truly
pause because there's H2 check on the
board right oh man or H takes g h H2
followed by
takes F3 is that wait a minute wait oh
yeah Rook F3 or was this a blunder no's
a mate where's the M what if I move the
bishop Bishop F4 and Knight G3 I don't
see the mate guys where's the mate
Bishop F3 he can just pick up the Rook
so he's up a
piece yes uh she takes F Knight F2 and
Knight D3 Knight C4 first why why did he
put his King on D6 happening well
because he can take with a rook on
F3 he did it and he just said hey uh two
pieces and the bond on H2 Ray said thank
you for playing brilliancy brilliant
game Let's jump to the game of Wesley so
and Fabby because Fabby in big trouble
nope he's down a couple of Pawns not
anymore not he's only down one pawn and
what did I miscount looks more like a
draw
yes things happen very quickly very
quickly I thought he was in big trouble
but I was
WR by the way aronian did win his game
against Sam shacklin back back victories
for Leon when we left it we saw that
move
cleanly and we have a draw between lir
is in clear first Karu versus Jeffrey
also a draw also a draw so we have only
this game left so in the competition of
Gary Kasparov versus America
America isn't doing very well man nobody
picked Gary I think he was uh
underestimated Gary and I think we all
underestimated Gary okay but what was
what was Wesley just doing there
he okay who's playing for a win I was
about to say he's not played it very
well as Wesley I'm still thinking he's
for choice right he awn he's the one
with the extra Pawn but gosh he's really
played it laxidasical I mean only way
white wins this is if he tricks him in
time trouble and can he do that the
clock times are what exactly 12 against
21 jeez jeez Louise that's too close
King D3 yes no King F3 okay that that's
playing it safe
yeah so is he going to throw in some
checks with Rook B6 no not yet King D3 o
don't knock it with the King now King E4
would be a draw on the spot right so
that's why he's not going but he's
allowing King F5 okay Knight oh King F5
F3 and possibly some o don't walk into
that pattern nice trick nice trick that
is a pattern we're familiar with but
even there I think there's no M what
about King D5 he's he's chosen your move
Christian ah he perhaps just simply
wants to go well Rook check and B5 no KN
check KN check I have Perpetual now with
Knight D7 and KN you always have a
perpet in the pocket where is he going
but leaving H2 and F2 unprotected
suggests to me you're going to take the
Perpetual right King
C5 y you are going to because the the
Knight and the Rook or disc coordinated
and that's a draw and not an
impressive uh technique that one for uh
Wesley the last round we got only two
wins with black pieces right aronian and
Kasparov exactly what a game by Gary
what a Game Boy
Ray that's that's wul as I'm just
replaying the game of Gary Kasparov and
Ray Robson on the board because quite
frankly it's left it's left us all
stunned
uh Ray Robson one of America's strongest
players a member of our Olympic team
just got upended in the worst possible
way and Gary winning two games with the
black pieces today impressive against
Wesley and R so in this position you
might take a look at the the position
and think to yourself well it's pretty
balanced from a material perspective uh
White on a good day if he ever plants
the night on E5 might look forward to
proceedings and literally from this
position onwards Gary just took over the
game uh and never looked back Knight D3
Bishop D6 B6 uh protecting the C5 Square
guess who's got control over the E
file F7 F6 position on play controlling
the E5 Square Bishop to G3 protect as
soon as I saw Bishop G3 I knew Gary was
going to win Knight's coming to D6 and
E4 and and this special little touch
Rook E4 tickling the Knight the Knight
drop back Rook E2 so we've gained the
tempo Knight E4 defends F6 what are you
going to do about your B5 I will seize
the
defensive very smooth giv King D6 and
then
H3 uh something by the way right here if
you don't mind uh Christian did the
engine approve of Rook h8 I know it's a
very good move but the for for for me
there was some
visual attractiveness I found to the
move G4 what yes G4 was very good was G4
was very very good uh but Rook to h8 did
not lose a bit any of the initiative at
all there were quite a few ways to win
this one Bishop to F4 was one of them G4
was another one Rook to h8 everything
very visual all of your pieces are
playing such an important crucial role
in the position in the attack right and
white has been struggling andg Rook D1
Rook B1 Rook D3 trying to find a way out
there's just simply no way out and I
mean Gary proved it in marvelous fashion
I have to say quite impressive fantastic
Bravo Gary Kasparov as we going to see
our standing take a picture as world
champion the 13th world champion makes a
remarkable return NY right after the
first day we have a sole leader Gary
casparo with plus two score you know if
I had take taken the pensioner you guys
would have laughed me out of the
building and I would boy talk about a
Miss Marquee moment for for me could
have should have would have you should
have would have could have I'm only
hearing excuses who's in second in
second place sharing Leon aronian and
saman congratulations and with 50%
Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano Carana Wesley so
and Sam Shanklin I have to say hikaro
dodh the bullet in one against Jeffrey
and Ray Robson uh suffering two uh very
painful defeats as
uhoo and and this is uh for tomorrow
again of course where we have three
rounds of Rapids each day and
Championship weekend coming up now see
all right so we have two more days and
round four will begin at 2:15 Central
Time right and um on Sunday we'll have
the last three rounds and repa the same
schedule yes in case somebody can catch
Gary Gary casparo and by the way it's
with Gary and not just Gary it's just
the nature of Chess itself um it's
momentum it's Trends you know when you
get on a roll just like Fabby had his
win streak here in the singfield cup uh
you went six four in a row row five in a
row you say well let's push it a little
bit more and see if we can't win play
against that confidence yeah exactly and
your opponent feels it as well Gary Gary
Kasparov on a roll when he was at his
prime it was
frightening and uh we're going to flip
it to uh Christian with a gra guest
Leana difficult start the tournament but
we could still see you on camera smiling
enjoying every single moment with your
uh friends and teammates because you
guys are creating some sort of Team
there analyzing these positions and
we've actually seen the influence of
that you in the last game against Sam
shanglin decided to go with G6 defend
upon on H7 like that but it wasn't a
comfortable position at all take us
through this game take us to tell us how
you adjusted after that first game um
you know generally I was playing well in
that first game it's just that I lost my
cool in the winning position so I just
told myself you know got to play the
same and maybe not go down on time so
much but this position oh my God from
move one we realized when we're
analyzing it's a difficult position all
the way yeah yeah we we really couldn't
figure out what to play here because I
thought C5 is is a very dangerous
symmetry with this Knight G3 and uh yeah
C5 I thought Knight Knight G3 CD and C3
were worried about this stuff yeah we
thought he take D and6 takes ah but E6
yeah yeah I think maybe we we
overestimated so the problem with D5
being yeah H4 or E4 yeah this things are
super scary you don't like it this one
yeah for good reason yeah C6 didn't feel
right but I what what happened we we
mostly assumed that people are going to
play first move C4 or C3 which we
thought C3 was very strong on move one
you know know C3 we thought is even
stronger because it kind of forces black
because now if G6 C4 seemed unpleasant
yes and now the bishop Pawn G7 is going
to be blocked by yeah yeah yeah and if
you play Knight G6 and H4 or you know
this uh yeah this this felt extremely
dangerous for black yep and one of those
positions one of those positions yeah
yeah and you don't have an engine to
analyze with yeah you have to work with
your team which is the closest engine
the engine in human form um a beast a
beast
uncaged and here I realized I'm in a lot
of trouble I hated my possession because
I can't do anything because if I play B6
then Knight D4 is so annoying you know
uh because Bishop D7 B4 that's it my
play stopped and he just developed so so
let say I just have to be
the yeah now before play stops a bishop
D7 I think because I cannot allow F5 yes
ah F5 here is also killing yeah yeah no
I had to be a Sitting Duck so I thought
well you know I'll just exchange the
Rooks and the Bishops and I'm in you
know it's a difficult position for me
Knight G4 Knight H6 Knight G4 Knight H6
what can I do what can I do but these
were the best moves it felt like finally
you're getting some play in you exchange
one critical piece and then finally you
yeah now I started kind of feeling that
I'm surviving after C5 I felt that C5
this is already this is already more or
less okay I'm still slightly
worse but I Will Survive somehow but
then C4 of course it was a pleasant
surprise mhm because here I saw I can
play B5 B6 but I thought B6 is more
conceptually right I I want to restrict
his Knight keep the and here I think yes
uh Sam started playing very dubious
moves Rook D1 is very dubious no I have
say he did not find the right plan to
and he had to stay put not do anything
uh rash I think he panicked somehow when
he realized that a good position that he
had is becoming you know not clear yeah
yeah and he gave you the pawn you took
it and after that you converted quite
beautifully I have to say Leon good
start for you um how did you prepare for
this tournament what's different about
Chess 9x compared to classical chess um
what are the big differences I think you
you really need to see tactics so I did
train some tactics before ter because
the game can get very sharp as you
probably saw in my game against Ry yes
yes it got really really sharp at some
moment and uh yeah I was happy that I
could see all of this so and one thing
you do very well is you almost never get
in time trouble and if you do your
opponent is in time trouble also how do
you prepare for that how do you force
yourself to have that mental I know that
this is my weakness you know playing in
uh time trouble and well I lost the
first game basically because of that so
I try to avoid getting in time trouble I
mean if I can sometimes you can't avoid
it but it's um just the experience that
I have some negative experience which is
also a positive experience cuz you know
you learn from everything yes
leavon thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow thank you uh leavon indeed as
leavon is one of the players TI for
second and uh got off to a bad start but
nice it finishes he was actually playing
really well in the game one he could
have won that one he would have had 100%
yeah yeah yeah the uh time trouble makes
fools of his all as Maurice Ashley would
say I'm still re uh recovering no
revealing re re reveling over uh Gary's
uh phenomenal score as he puts up uh two
victories in one draw to a snatch the
first place all by himself and uh well
uh Christian with a special guest Sam
great start for you bitting one of the
tournament favorites player that always
says that he loves chess uh n Le that is
Leon aronian take us through this game
tell us how you approach this one how
did you prepare also for this tournament
uh I'm honestly mainly doing tactics
before the games because the positions
are so insane and have so many complex
patterns that it's hard to just look at
one position because all of them are
different how do you deal whenever you
see a pattern that you've never seen in
your life and finally it's something
completely different we've seen Ray on
the camera smiling sometimes when he's
missing a move or when he's finding a
fabulous move how do you react to that
yeah I mean that's the beauty of this
game there's so many different ideas and
when you see you haven't seen before all
you can do is just admire what's
happening on the board absolutely and
we've seen so many of those situations
take us through the first game D4 leevon
was saying that he had a good position
at one point uh this was very
interesting but probably Queen before
was in in accuracy
mhm that's funny that it's been played
online
d850 versus Zoo Paris yeah I mean what I
misunderstood was after whatever he
plays to protect the Knight then he
plays a five next M and basically either
equalizer just gets a nice position yeah
so he went for
E5 uh long Castle B6 yeah so here I'm
just slightly worse
um I was a bit happy that he went for
this end game because I mean even though
it's bad for white it's not that easy to
win yeah because uh my Knight's on F4
It's Tricky it's kind of like a blockade
on the king side yes and then we got I
think it was somewhere around here after
you guys traded off yeah once we got to
this position I mean I thought I have
good chances because uh the knights are
always very tricky yes yes and it wasn't
easy at all he only had one particular
moment I think it was at this point when
he could have played um C4 right here
but it wasn't easy before Bishop H6 H6
and then this is some sort of a okay
that's impossible with no time yes yes
yes and because you have to time it
basically right and he had like 14
seconds on his I mean uh objectively
it's probably good for black but with no
time it's hard to play with black
because I mean you move you you move the
bishop you lose all the puns so were you
playing for a win right now were you
with at this point I was definitely
playing for a win playing for a win yeah
that's the mentality yeah right and now
he was just waiting for the king to go
to to the wrong Square to the wrong
Square yeah yes and it did and yeah at
this point King to B6 King to C6 still
shuffling the pieces finally I went kn4
and took this far yeah and King takes G3
and now B4 and now he has to move the
king because I'm pinned yeah yes King D7
or King to B7 and then Bishop takes C3
and somehow this position is still equal
it's a very study like position but he
took on C3 and at this point he probably
understood that you're winning get back
in time Sam congratulations uh good
start for you uh no losses up to this
point how would you assess your
performance what's the plan for tomorrow
uh I mean three very interesting
positions and I think through very
fighting games but like all of the games
have been decided in the blitz bullet
portion of the game so at the end of the
day it's still rapid chest and you have
to be very sharp so I'm just going to
try playing quick and good moves I'm
curious who did you team up with and
what do you guys usually do what do you
do for those 15 minutes in between the
position reveal and the start of the
game uh we I teamed up with a lot of
people Ray Sam Jeffrey and then hikaro
for the second game so everyone has
different styles and different
understanding of the game so it's very
interesting wle as well Sam thank you
very much we'll see you tomorrow all
right thank you quick question for you
Sam if you don't mind uh just uh uh
you're one of the youngest uh players in
the tournament and yet the ican cometh
uh Gary Kasparov 60-year-old Gary
Kasparov is leading the tournament uh
you expected
that I mean it's pretty amazing I looked
at the standings after round two and I
saw his name at the top and I was like
okay he's he's he's informed for this
one very good thank you Sam good luck uh
in day two as the weekend comes up we'll
be playing three games tomorrow Saturday
three games tomorrow Sunday tell your
friends where you're hanging out as we
have the guy who's in first place coming
up uh to be interviewed and quite a
remarkable story uh we must say as we
catch our breaths and say Gary casar off
in the house nassi yeah and I wonder
which game Christian's going to ask him
about cuz all his games were so exciting
well that last one Robson was uh wow uh
that was just this disos that I have in
front of me on my board where I'm just
looking at that Rook h8 I mean all of
Black's pieces everyone of Black's
pieces is in harmony with the other to
conduct a a winning yeah winning attack
position and uh the man of the moment uh
Gary casparo with Christian Gary I asked
you yesterday after the ultimate moves
event how are you feeling and you said
that I'm feeling the pieces right now
you definitely showed that in today's
games and I have to say that last game
it was just a masterpiece give us your
emotions right now look you know I I
think that's somehow you know I'm
receiving back you know the points that
I lost last year it's
because it's if you remember the the
first day last year so I had a bet
probably slightly better game against L
one which I lost very very badly and
then two winning positions against uh
Fabby against hiar and Fab so I started
zero out of three so and it had a huge
effect on me so what H what's happening
now is that I decided that you know I
have to trust my hand he is my brains
are not as fast as they used to be but
hand is still there you know so and uh
the last game you mentioned
just you know I knew it was right so
just I played very quickly at the end
because everything went you know just
the right POS you found every piece
found the right spot so that's the end
uh but again I I felt very good because
the first game was vessely was very
important so I I was
still not uncomfortable but just tensed
and it was really serious game I mean
this is he just you know it looked
position looked equal but you know he he
always created threats and and then I
just you know instinctively I decided so
I could go go for this risk because you
know when play H3 actually yes it's the
yes this is the yeah it's
the yeah so the yeah this important is I
made Castle here this which is you know
it's interesting because I played Knight
D4 provoke C3 so just say I'm most you
creative but still you know it's a
little bit dangerous because you know
black is behind p is hanging but you
know uh but here is just you know I can
easily go it's this take on4 so H3 and
now I just you know I I have to say that
I'm I I'm missed you know E4 Queen D3
Knight E5 Queen C2 so that's what just
this which one E4 Queen D I thought
Knight D5 Knight D5 and then I saw Queen
C2 and then D4 yes so this is yeah this
is yeah it's terrible so I just I um and
uh um which is again this is It's the um
I uh think it's just it's the uh is uh
yeah it's funny that it's it's actually
here it's probably this this move F3 in
this position yes yes still F3 so that's
that's something take F2 okay Bishop F5
check yes yeah then then King B8 and
you're still hanging on I'm still still
hanging on I'm again just R tonight this
slightly worse position but you're still
hanging it's not not good so it's the
and I just yeah I I sense Bishop A6
probably I'm holding probably hold again
it's it's it's very Bishop A6 you know e
took on C6 Knight F3 and this this yes
this is the and as night of three and I
just you know if you if you you want to
go Que because the move that you want to
do now is something like queen queen
queen D7 but then I just you know I
wasn't sure what what happens after
after Queen A6 maybe that's the best and
then and then Rook E4 Rook E4 maybe C5
and Knight G5 Queen C probably I should
go Queen Knight G5 that's what was was I
was afraid M ah but that's that's bad
yes Bishop to D5 Bishop D5 yes yeah
that's yes this is and I guess you hide
this G yes this is so but maybe that was
the best but I just sense that you know
I could go Queen B7 and it was very
interesting because you know when he
played um Queen E4 uh I mean I vle was
but I saw it Bishop E5 yes and and I saw
that if he goes which is that's I go
immediately they count counter push
Queen D7 que D3 bishop5 so again it's
here dangerous position again Vis but
Bishop on B2 but you feeling safe but
Bishop on B2 again it's and the moment
you know I change all these good pieces
Bishop W be2 and my Bishop potentially I
already had a dream that when play C3 I
said maybe one you know when you play
after C3 you know maybe I play Queen
distri Dream Dream came through yes
that's it that's it that's that's and
that's pretty much game yeah that's
that's that's that's it so that's the um
and um and then get the second round so
I just you know was Karu you know it
looked for me that's the opening was
good so that's it but it's the when you
what yes D5 93 you spent a lot of time
yeah but but to do I mean just I I don't
know what just it's the probably you
should start playing something slowly
Queen B2 Bishop B3 so that's again
just maybe bishop D2 I wasn't sure can I
do that Bishop D2 i s but maybe yeah the
actually agrees with your decision just
take on D5 exchange like that yeah it's
sort of a slight flight Edge but it was
not true but it's is the eventually I
won the pawn which is again it's it's
yeah I just had a little pressure but uh
yeah actually I just Bishop F4 I missed
but just Bop but he just made a very
strong move Knight C4 of course yeah
very just you know he gave up the pawn
and and here I just start okay I have an
extra Pawn but you know I'm not probably
better yes yeah and but you know it's
it's a time should I try to win or just
should I and I just I I couldn't make a
decision and I just got in real trouble
I think the end game was totally lost
yeah oh clearly lost and but I just was
very proud because hikaro I I found the
study like draw at the end now the end
game is is is really is bad you felt bad
about he just simply instead of Rook C4
F5 F4 you know he could have put PA
seems like this was perhaps the moment
and even early without having Rook on A4
Rook D3 and basically bring King on E5 I
didn't see this how King goes on E5 so
this is this is the I just want to
provoke his Rook because otherwise King
goes on5 F5 F4 there's nothing I can do
that's yeah F5 F4 totally lost and he
decided I think I think when he just
moved this Rook you know suddenly and
then you know just I found I just it's
because I I calculated at four and first
you know I S take take take yes this is
this is take take I just s King D6 King
D3 King C5 see King D3 yes King D King
C5 I I thought A4 is the draw but then
King D5 A4 King D5 and he's winning yes
this is he's winning H4 A5 yes and and
and he also saw it yes but King C3 is a
study like move so I I was very proud
that's that's an immediate draw so no
absolutely you are actually blitzing out
through this moves very confident it's I
have the 10 seconds left so that's but
again hand hand so that's this you
remember this is it's all it's all
worked out and so this I have to ask you
about the last game because this last
game this by the way I I have to I don't
know what's the impression of I think
this is the worst position for black
opening position we ever had open
opening position I don't know what was
the outcome this is because it's the the
D4 I think C4 is very dangerous this is
what leevon said as well I think but C4
I don't know 6 H4 is proba the lost and
C4 C4 no C C4 C4 we will watch it we
look at this I don't know what's
happened in the games What's happen
Hikaru game Hikaru played this against
Jeffrey yes and uh he got a good
position very good position yeah E3
yeah yeah but that's the and he was
probably yeah but look at this position
plus one so this this position is real
after C4 I would probably play G6 G6
probably G6 because I I couldn't we
couldn't find anything with with Wesley
and Hikaru so this is it's probably
worst it's probably worst position that
for for black that is that we ever had
this is this is definitely should be
marked some of the position should be
probably marked because it's really
unpleasant right so he played D4 it's
which is also interesting so D4 and um
and it's the because it's also yes D4 D5
yes and uh c yeah okay here going to
play E4 and I and I think I just my only
move was E5 I wasn't sure it's e D5 cd5
I'm not sure it's the it's oh yeah this
is terrible yeah Bishop D7 I thought
maybe I still can hold take take can I
guess you're just like one move away E4
yeah can I take on D4 maybe Rook uh H
okay but that's H that's that's this
machine exactly that's the yeah I so
maybe I could have hold but but E4 H4
was also dangerous but then I think I
just found I found really good maneuver
the defensive Manu Bishop que Knight C7
E3 knight6 Bishop D3 take take Queen D6
Bishop here I just I thought about I
could have taken on F5 immed that's why
I spend time interesting and now just
says this and I S about Queen
H2 but and if he goes Castle but King E2
King E2 maybe that's unpleasant because
canel this side no canel because then
then then then you cannot trap my queen
after A6 Knight G3 H4 Rook H1 doesn't
work because a free square is still
working but I wasn't sure as it's still
maybe possible yes but there the but
reason to take on A5 just you know to
make sure that Queen cannot go on G4
because after Queen F5 Bishop F5 Queen
takes F5 yeah Queen takes A5 here uh E6
yeah you you don't have the same
comfortable Square for H4 is coming the
also also maybe queen3 bishop E7 for so
that's because my position is a little
but I I wasn't sure about Knight takes
F5 yeah yeah this Pawn is hanging yeah
so and and but I okay I can just play H4
and and it's and that's was a very
important one E6 E5 it's only move
because I I have to play E5 now no no no
I play E6 E6 and then E5 yeah and yeah I
could have play probably immediately A5
also just you know I wasn't sure because
the idea is Queen E6 key is a queen E6
uhhuh Queen yes I wasn't sure with
what's the what's the right move but
somehow I sense that you have this E5
and F4 is looks winning but after Queen
D7 first time white has a strategic risk
so the idea being
that7 and then Castle G
and that's the and that's yes and white
is in trouble and one Temple away
exactly yeah one temp away and this is
this yeah he missing one Temple but
black and Castle safely Castle you still
have Castle on the other so he just he
took there and I think I just I I play
the end game I play well F5 ni rookie
eight is import now it's interesting you
know this because it's always you play
F6 G6 but it's too early it's just to
fix the pawn five but it's too early you
have to take the bishop away take E4
Square I already saw this all all the
squares you know yeah all the squares
this and and then that's just you don't
need to take points he had no moves yeah
no moves yes AB no moves yes I mean this
must be yeah yeah beautiful finish to
the game yeah it's a good game yes so
again I I I don't know what will happen
tomorrow so but yeah I I enjoyed it I
enjoyed it and um and uh again if I keep
this the same correct balance between
the hand and brains so I could do well
yes sir Nazi join the conversation
congratulations Gary I mean no seriously
it's wonderful to see you uh playing
successfully still though Gary if I
could reprimand you your time management
still need to work on
that yes yes yes yes yes there's always
room for
improvement work on it good luck
tomorrow fantastic thank you thank you
AB absolutely thank you Gary half out of
three but there is still room for
improvement of course of course always
and here's what our day looks like our
standings n e Gary Kasparov in the lead
with two and a half points and then
closely following with two points Leon
aronian and Sam saan fantastic at 50%
four
players hiar hikaro Nakamura Fabiano
caruana wesle and Sam Shanklin nice
lanir and Jeffrey on minus one Ray
Robson on minus two again Ray suffering
time trouble problems but in this
particular case of round
three a good play from his opponent and
bring it home for us uh Christian final
thoughts of this very eventful I mean I
have to say just a brilliant day of uh
chess 9x not chess classical chess but
chess 9x and it's always a pleasure
whenever Gary does well and you could
sense it from him as well exuding
confidence when he came here in the
studio show us all these incredible
lines and you can taste the
understanding still uh he's just an
amazing player it's a pleasure to have
him here in St Louis and everybody else
have been showing incredible pace and
incredible chess I have to say Ray
Robson has to speed things up a little
bit you cannot think for five minutes on
move one that's just simply unacceptable
work on that R and come back stronger
tomorrow is going to be a fantastic day
too thank you Christian indeed it it
will be NY it was wonderful great great
fun we hope you enjoyed our show tell
your friends where you're hanging out
join us tomorrow same time same channel
good night till then thank you and see
you
[Music]
tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited